Hey guys, this is Sean, I know in a previous intro I talked about like working out, getting my legs bigger, getting my thighs bigger, getting my arms bigger, just getting everything, like I'm just jumped and packed and jacked and whacked and I was just like, so then after that I thought maybe I'd work on my feet because my feet need to be just as like great as the rest of my body and then after that I thought I'd look around my toes like around my toes and my fingertips and I just thought wow, I'm just kidding, I haven't worked out in years. Welcome to Smart List. Hey, you know, I just want to say something, Jay, I don't know if you know this, but today
嘿，伙计们，我是肖恩。我知道在之前的开场白里我谈到了健身，比如练粗我的腿，练粗我的大腿，练粗我的手臂，就是练全身，就像我整个人都练得结实、强壮、充满活力，然后在那之后，我想也许我该练练我的脚，因为我的脚也需要像我身体的其他部位一样棒，然后在那之后，我想我该看看我的脚趾，还有我的手指尖，我当时就想，哇，我开玩笑呢，我已经好几年没锻炼了。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。嘿，你知道吗，我只想说一件事，杰森，我不知道你知不知道，但今天
you use a heavy bronzer? Today? I know, look at it. Listener, Will's back from the Caribbean. The French Polynesian. Not Polynesian. South Pacific. No, not South Pacific, the French Antilles. Do you put Sun Black on or no? Yes, of course. No, he doesn't. He puts on olive oil is what he does. No, I don't. By the way, I met a lot of really nice, smart list listeners. Really? Oh, in the Caribbean. Yeah, in the Caribbean. And my buddy, Todd, who I met. Oh, sure. Sure. We don't need names, man. Who's Todd from the Caribbean? He's just a guy. Did you compliment him on his first name? He and his wife. He said, he drew a comparison. He said that Todd happens to be the name of your character from Teen
你用了很重的古铜色修容粉吗？今天？我知道，看看它。听众朋友们，威尔从加勒比海回来了。法属波利尼西亚。不是波利尼西亚。南太平洋。不，不是南太平洋，是法属安的列斯群岛。你涂防晒霜了吗？涂了，当然。不，他没涂。他涂的是橄榄油。不，我没有。顺便说一句，我遇到了很多非常好的《SmartLess》听众。真的吗？哦，在加勒比海。是的，在加勒比海。还有我的哥们托德，我遇到了他。哦，当然。当然。我们不需要名字，伙计。那个来自加勒比海的托德是谁？他只是个普通人。你夸奖他的名字了吗？他和他的妻子。他说，他做了一个比较。他说托德正好是你《少狼》里角色的名字
Wolf. Oh, that is true. So, boy, thank him for watching. Limited channels down there on the island. He kept the lights on for you, buddy. So it's just maybe we're playing on the latest. Jason, today's a very special day. It's Sean's birthday. Oh, yes. Thank you. Well, you didn't say anything, but thank you. I wasn't going to mention it at all. Happy birthday, Sean. That's very sweet. Listen, when people get over their sixties, they don't want to celebrate at all, Will. It's true. It's true. Wait, by the way, you guys, I shit you not. Can you read that? Dear Sean, happy birthday from all of us at Garfield Pharmacy. We are wishing you all the best for the coming year. From a pharmacy.
哦，那倒是真的。所以，伙计，谢谢他观看。岛上的频道很有限。他为你留着灯呢，伙计。所以也许我们正在播放最新的节目。杰森，今天是一个非常特别的日子。今天是肖恩的生日。哦，是的。谢谢。好吧，你什么都没说，但谢谢你。我本来根本没打算提。生日快乐，肖恩。那太贴心了。听着，当人们过了六十岁，他们根本不想庆祝，威尔。这是真的。这是真的。等等，顺便说一句，伙计们，我没骗你们。你能读一下那个吗？亲爱的肖恩，加菲尔德药房全体员工祝你生日快乐。我们祝你在新的一年里一切顺利。来自一家药房。
You know, this qualifies as a bit of a flair. It's a crazy pharmacy texted me. Sean, Garfield Pharmacy, did they help you put together that bath you were talking about where you can open the side of it and you can get into it? The one with the door. I thought you were going to say it sits back. Is that your crew? Now, Sean, happy, Will, let's do that fastest happy birthday to you song ever. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you, Sean. Happy birthday to you. Sean, you are an absolute, I will say this. You're an incredible friend. Jason, you know this. There have been so many times, I'm not surprised, but there have been so many awesome times I can think of within
你知道，这算是一种小小的炫耀。这是一家疯狂的药房给我发短信。肖恩，加菲尔德药房，他们帮你组装了你一直在说的那个可以打开侧面进去的浴缸了吗？就是带门的那种。我以为你会说它能向后倾斜。那是你的团队吗？好了，肖恩，快乐，威尔，让我们来唱那首史上最快的生日快乐歌吧。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐，肖恩。祝你生日快乐。肖恩，你绝对是一个，我会这么说。你是一个不可思议的朋友。杰森，你知道这一点。有太多次了，我并不感到惊讶，但我能想到在
the last month where things were going on and you just reach out in a way that a lot of other people would feel like, well, I'll just let them kind of marinate. And you just reach out and call and go, Hey, are you okay? Yeah. And Sean, I love you for it. I love you guys. I love you too. Yeah. I did that with you too, Jay. I do that. I do that because I love you guys more than anything. Listener, if you ever get the chance to be friends with Sean Hayes, it's the best. I highly recommend it. It's the trial. Do a trial first. And by the way, but now we mentioned we love Sean. We love you so much. But there are people who don't obviously one of the, one of the people is scavo obviously because I don't
过去的一个月里，发生了很多很棒的事情，你总是以一种让很多人觉得“好吧，我会让他们自己消化一下”的方式伸出援手。而你总是主动打电话说，嘿，你还好吗？是的。肖恩，我爱你这一点。我爱你们。我也爱你们。是的，我也对你做过同样的事，杰。我这样做。我这样做是因为我爱你们胜过一切。听众朋友们，如果你有机会和肖恩·海耶斯成为朋友，那是最好的。我强烈推荐。先试用一下。顺便说一句，既然我们提到了我们爱肖恩。我们非常爱你。但显然有些人不爱，其中一个人显然是斯卡沃，因为我不知道
know what's going on. Or did you get a fight with his scissors or him? I know. Look at it. That's great. That's what that's what's coming for me on Wednesday. Really? Finally going to cut. Yeah. For folks who can't see, I've got a, I've got a whole head of hair that's 30 pounds of hair. Are you, when are you done? Oh, I just finished. I was doing a job where I had to play a fellow that was living in 1984. It's a 1984 thing. And so all this feathering was really appropriate. Now it's not. And so it's coming down on Wednesday. But what was the excuse before you got the part? Exactly. Yeah. Cause it was long for a minute. Yeah. But then I was about to cut it and then didn't cause I got
发生了什么。还是你和他的剪刀或者他本人打了一架？我知道。看看它。那太棒了。这就是周三要发生在我身上的事。真的吗？终于要剪了。是的。对于那些看不见的人，我有一头头发，那是30磅重的头发。你，你什么时候剪完？哦，我刚剪完。我之前在做一份工作，我必须扮演一个生活在1984年的家伙。这是一个1984年的设定。所以所有这些羽毛剪发型真的很合适。现在不合适了。所以周三就要剪掉了。但在你接到那个角色之前，借口是什么？正是如此。是的。因为有一段时间它很长。是的。但后来我正要剪掉它，结果没剪，因为我接到了
this job. I actually think it looks cool along. Thank you. Wait, really fast, super fast, quick birthday story from when I was like, I don't know, 22. My mom thought it'd be so great to put instead of candles on a cake, she put sparklers, like 20 of them. I could like that. Not realizing that sparklers, you know, our fireworks basically, and they don't blow out. And so she lit all of them and the whole fucking thing like lit up, caught fire. And then she's cutting. And then after she put it all out, she's, you know, she's like happy birthday and there's fucking fireworks all over. You mess around with fireworks. You lose an eye. Well, that's nice, man. And then she cut the cake and it tasted like sulfur.
这份工作。我其实觉得它留长发看起来很酷。谢谢。等等，很快，超级快，讲一个关于我大概22岁时的生日小故事。我妈妈觉得在蛋糕上不插蜡烛，而是插上烟花，大概20根，那会很棒。我可以点燃它。她没意识到烟花，你知道，基本上就是爆竹，而且它们吹不灭。所以她把它们全点着了，整个该死的东西就像着火了一样。然后她正在切。然后等她把火全扑灭后，你知道，她说生日快乐，到处都是该死的烟花。你玩弄烟花。你会瞎了一只眼。好吧，那很好，伙计。然后她切了蛋糕，尝起来像硫磺。
Nothing on eye, nothing on the eye joke at all. Maybe Tracy's laughing. Put an eye out. You know who likes to laugh. Oh, what a great segue. What a great. Hey, by the way, does anybody work a segue better than me? Double entendre. Double entendre. Double entendre. Okay. Let me tell you something. Let me tell you something. This guy. This guy. Can I tell you something about this guy? Here's something you didn't know about this guy because you both know this country. Things I don't know. Here's something. His parents. Yeah. His parents, couple of nice folks, or both satellite engineers, satellite engineers, try engineers one more time. Still wrong. Worked on engineers, engineers. Worked on a Minuteman nuclear missile guidance
完全没有关于眼睛的笑话。也许特蕾西在笑。弄瞎一只眼。你知道谁喜欢笑。哦，多么棒的过渡。多么棒的。嘿，顺便问一下，有人比我更会做过渡吗？双关语。双关语。双关语。好吧。让我告诉你一件事。让我告诉你一件事。这家伙。这家伙。我能告诉你关于这家伙的一件事吗？这是你不知道的关于这家伙的事，因为你们俩都知道这个国家。我不知道的事情。这是其中之一。他的父母。是的。他的父母，一对很好的人，都是卫星工程师，卫星工程师，再试一次工程师。还是错的。致力于工程师，工程师。致力于民兵核导弹制导
system. Wow. Apollo lunar module guidance system. The science of the ground station of the Hubble space telescope. Things like of this nature. And then this person is about he plays soccer. Let's book the parents. How about that? Okay. Hang on a second. And then this person, you would know them. No way he's going to be as interesting. Let me think about how you're going to know this person. You might know this person from some of these. Some of the. Wow. Take your time. Real perfect. I'm just trying to think of some of the things you would know them from picket fences, maybe golden palace. These are appearances. Northern exposure. X files. Oh, maybe not. Maybe from the jackal. No, enemy of the state. You're
系统。哇。阿波罗登月舱制导系统。哈勃太空望远镜地面站的科学。诸如此类的事情。然后这个人，他踢足球。我们预订他的父母吧。怎么样？好的。等一下。然后这个人，你会认识他们的。他不可能那么有趣。让我想想你会怎么认识这个人。你可能从这些节目中认识这个人。其中一些。哇。慢慢来。真完美。我只是在想一些你会从哪里认识他们。可能是《栅栏篱笆》，也许是《黄金宫殿》。这些是客串。 《北国风云》。 《X档案》。哦，也许不是。也许是从《豺狼的日子》。不， 《国家公敌》。你
saving the real one for later. Water world. Demolition man. No, you'd probably know this person more from shallow howl, not to liberate tenacious deed. The picket nest, and school rocket. Mr. Jack. Look at that face. It's gorgeous. I've just been back here behind my little toilet paper hiding spot. Are you in the toilet right now? Well, your producers said I have to hide myself with like something and I don't have a handkerchief or anything. So I just. You usually have a hanky your old school like that. You've got like an old school hanky on you all the time. And he offers it to people who are crying, even though it's not stained. Quick plug. My buddy Colin Hanks has a handkerchief company called Hanks kerchief.
把真正的那个留到后面了。 《未来水世界》。 《超级战警》。不，你可能更多地从《庸人哈尔》认识这个人，不是《摇滚校园》， 《摇滚之王》。 《摇滚校园》。杰克。看看那张脸。太华丽了。我刚才一直躲在我的小卫生纸藏身处后面。你现在在厕所里吗？嗯，你的制片人说我必须用某种东西把自己藏起来，我没有手帕之类的东西。所以我只是。你通常有一条手帕，你是那种老派的人。你总是带着一条老派的手帕。而且他会把它递给正在哭泣的人，即使它没有污渍。快速植入广告。我的哥们科林·汉克斯有一家手帕公司叫Hanks Kerchief。
Not true. Is that true? 100% true. Check it out. As I have a mold removal company called adjacent abatement that I want to send you say everybody. Listen, Jack, by the way, at any point, I love it so much at any point. If you want to just do a little side, like a little quick plug ski for friends, I'm down with it. I hated having that right out of the gate, but I couldn't not talk about my you talked handkerchiefs and like that's that's the first place I go. Now, first of all, we got two J.B.s here for the first time. I mean, this is my God, right? Let's go with let's go with Jack. I mean, it's not a better name than Jack. You be J.B. today. Oh, you want to hold on to J.B.? Were you ever Jack? Were
不是真的。那是真的吗？100%是真的。去看看吧。就像我有一家叫Adjacent Abatement的除霉公司，我想发给你，告诉大家。听着，杰克，顺便说一句，在任何时候，我都很喜欢这样，在任何时候。如果你想做一个小小的侧面，就像一个小小的快速植入广告，我没问题。我讨厌刚开始就这么做，但我不能不谈我的你谈到了手帕，那是我第一个想到的地方。现在，首先，我们这里有两个J.B.。我的天哪，对吧？让我们叫杰克吧。我的意思是，没有比杰克更好的名字了。你今天就是J.B.。哦，你想保留J.B.吗？你曾经是杰克吗？你曾经
you ever a John? What? No. In fact, my real name is Thomas. No, it's not Thomas black back up a second. Is it really Sean? Where are you coming from? Thomas Jacob, right, Jack? That's right. Thomas Jacob black. So if I wanted to go short for Jacob, it would have been Jake black. You don't want to have been good for you. Well, TJ. TJ black. TJ. Yeah, not bad. Different career. So I can understand if his name was Henry, you'd ask him if he was ever Hank, but is our Jack's ever John? Yes. Yeah, of course. That's where Jack comes from. Lots of Johns and Jonathan's are John F. Kennedy. Thank you. Don't scream at me. Now, Jack, I got the J.B. and I never asked for it. Did you ever ask for J.B.? I
是约翰吗？什么？不。事实上，我的真名是托马斯。不，不是托马斯·布莱克，退后一步。真的是肖恩吗？你从哪儿来的？托马斯·雅各布，对吧，杰克？没错。托马斯·雅各布·布莱克。所以如果我想用雅各布的缩写，那应该是杰克·布莱克。你不想那样，对你来说很好。好吧，T.J.。T.J.布莱克。T.J.。是的，还不错。不同的职业。所以我能理解如果他的名字是亨利，你会问他是否曾经是汉克，但我们的杰克曾经是约翰吗？是的。是的，当然。这就是杰克的由来。很多约翰和乔纳森，约翰·F·肯尼迪。谢谢。别对我大喊大叫。现在，杰克，我有了J.B.，但我从来没要求过。你曾经要求过J.B.吗？我
didn't know. You don't you're not. It's not cool to ask for your nickname. That's not the way it's supposed to go. Exactly. But then, but I'm afraid people think that I have asked for it when somebody when somebody calls me that because it sounds like J.B., you know, like I'm some sort of a power figure or authority. That's like a boss. But you can't ask your nickname. Let's ask pants wetter. Sean, sorry. Yeah. What are you? What are you? I didn't have to ask for that. No. Jack, Jack, I can't believe it's taken us this long to have you here. I know. We can't make his deal. We can't make his deal. I feel like. It's such a layup that you would be, we just, I adore you and just think you're the freaking greatest
不知道。你不是。要求自己的绰号是不酷的。这不是它应该有的方式。正是如此。但后来，我担心人们认为是我要求的，当有人叫我那个名字时，因为它听起来像J.B.，你知道，就像我是某种权力人物或权威。就像老板一样。但你不能要求你的绰号。让我们问问尿裤子的人。肖恩，抱歉。是的。你是谁？你是谁？我没必要要求那个。不。杰克，杰克，我不敢相信我们花了这么长时间才请到你。我知道。我们不能达成他的交易。我们不能达成他的交易。我觉得。你来这里真是太顺理成章了，我们只是，我崇拜你，觉得你是最棒的
and I just can't believe it's taken forever, man. I'll second that. Well, the feeling is muc. I'm a huge fan of all three of you individually and collectively. Do you remember, do you remember when we all used to play poker at Kyle's house together? Yes. Yes. We all partied over at Kyle Gass's house to play poker. Kyle Gass is my partner in Tenacious D. That's right. But now, are you still playing cards and music with Kyle Gass, with the K-Jerrific? I am playing music with Kyle Gass. We're still touring and we got a very big project coming up that I can't really tell you anything about, but we got a concept album coming down the pike. A one more sip of that morning coffee there and then you'll feel like telling us.
我简直不敢相信这花了这么久，伙计。我附议。好吧，感觉是相互的。我是你们三个人个人和集体的超级粉丝。你还记得，你还记得我们以前都在凯尔家一起玩扑克吗？是的。是的。我们都在凯尔·加斯的家里聚会玩扑克。凯尔·加斯是我的Tenacious D乐队搭档。没错。但现在，你还在和凯尔·加斯，那个K-Jerrific一起打牌和玩音乐吗？我正在和凯尔·加斯玩音乐。我们还在巡演，我们有一个非常大的项目即将推出，我不能真的告诉你任何事情，但我们有一个概念专辑即将推出。再喝一口那早晨的咖啡，然后你就会想告诉我们了。
I haven't had any. Does it seem like I'm amped and jazzed? No, no. I was trying to make a booze joke, you know, and you say, have one more sip of that drink and then you'll tell me. All right. Well, maybe later. Maybe we'll earn it at the end of the session here. So maybe we'll earn it. Maybe we'll gain your confidence, but I will say this. So, Jack, just so we can get back to Cage for a second for one sec, Kyle Gass in his poker game. First of all, what are the odds that he's in a sleeveless sweatshirt right now? Very high. That's his whole thing. That's his loose football practice shorts. Can I tell you something? And slides. He's always about the comfort. So Jack's partner, Kyle Gass,
我还没喝呢。我看起来很兴奋和激动吗？不，不。我只是想开个酒的玩笑，你知道，你说，再喝一口那杯饮料，然后你就会告诉我。好吧，也许晚点吧。也许我们在会议结束时会赢得它。所以也许我们会赢得它。也许我们会获得你的信任，但我会说这一点。所以，杰克，为了让我们回到Cage的话题，就一秒钟，凯尔·加斯在他的扑克游戏中。首先，他现在穿着无袖运动衫的几率是多少？非常高。那是他的全部风格。那是他的宽松足球训练短裤。我能告诉你一件事吗？还有拖鞋。他总是追求舒适。所以杰克的搭档，凯尔·加斯，
who he just alluded to in his partner in Tenacious D, and they made a number of records and movies and the TV show for a few years, all of it. One time, so we all played in this poker game. I forget who was our first entree into the game, but it was a Tuesday night game. You used to play and then we came into it a little bit later and then we brought, and then Richter was in it and Sean was in it. I remember Sean came in the first night, won a bunch and there was like, I got to go home guys. And everybody's like, you're not going bucking the handyman. The Walsh brothers were not having that. No. And we had Matt Walsh and, you know, we had a Patti Walsh and we had everybody. Right. So then we played in that for a couple of years
他刚才提到的他在Tenacious D的搭档，他们制作了许多唱片、电影和电视节目，几年了，所有这些。有一次，我们都在这个扑克游戏中玩。我忘了谁是我们进入游戏的第一个引路人，但那是一个周二晚上的游戏。你以前常玩，然后我们晚一点加入，然后我们带了，然后里希特在里面，肖恩也在里面。我记得肖恩第一晚进来，赢了一大笔，然后就像，我得回家了，伙计们。每个人都说，你不能走，该死的杂工。沃尔什兄弟可不答应。不。我们有马特·沃尔什，你知道，我们有帕蒂·沃尔什，我们有所有人。对。所以我们在那玩了几年
and there was a lot of dough was exchanged back and forth in some, some fireworks here and there. And Kage used to have the clown car and then he had the celebrity clown car. Literally, remember you had that car and you put people in it. But Jack, what I was getting to was, I remember going to, you were hosting SNL once and Kage was coming. And so he said, and I was going back to New York cause Amy was still on the show at the time. And he's like, what fight are you? I go, I'm going to take the red eye on Friday night. He goes, I'll come on the same flight. I'll meet you at LAX. I go, great. So I text him with or whatever I go, I'll meet you at the gate and Kage shows up at the gate and he's in his sleeveless sweatshirt
有很多钱在来回交换，还有一些，一些烟花。Kage以前有一辆小丑车，然后他有了名人小丑车。真的，记得你有那辆车，你把人塞进去。但杰克，我要说的是，我记得去，你曾经主持过SNL，Kage要来。所以他说，我要回纽约，因为艾米当时还在节目里。他说，你坐哪趟航班？我说，我要坐周五晚上的红眼航班。他说，我也坐那趟航班。我在LAX机场见你。我说，太好了。所以我给他发短信或者什么的，我说，我在登机口见你，Kage出现在登机口，他穿着他的无袖运动衫
in shorts and flips. And he's got every single glossy celeb rag in a pile. And I go, and I go, Kage, what are you doing? Get away from me, man. What are you, what are you doing? Yeah. He likes reading those. He loves to read up on the celebs, on the latest got the hot goss. Now are you guys still playing cards at all, Jack? No, I haven't been playing with, with Kage. We haven't been playing cards. I miss it. And once in a while, you know, whenever there's like a charity poker game, I like to jump in there because I do love it. But I do find that when I lose inevitably, it does hurt. It excruciate, there's an excruciating pain and regret that lasts for days.
和短裤，还有人字拖。他手里拿着每一本光鲜亮丽的名人杂志。我说，我说，Kage，你在干什么？离我远点，伙计。你在，你在干什么？是的。他喜欢读那些。他喜欢读关于名人的最新八卦，热辣的八卦。现在你们还在打牌吗，杰克？不，我没和Kage一起玩。我们没在打牌。我很怀念它。偶尔，你知道，每当有像慈善扑克游戏这样的活动时，我喜欢加入，因为我确实很喜欢它。但我发现当我不可避免地输掉时，它确实很痛。有一种极其痛苦和后悔的感觉，持续好几天。
Or it's like, God dang it. If I would have just, you know what I did? I didn't have the balls to call. Why didn't I just call? I had queens. And it'll stick with me and I'll feel like an idiot. And then when I get up from the table, like, all right, guys, hope everyone had a good, good, good time. And as I'm leaving, I can see in their eyes, they just have this poison of like, yes, we beat you. We made you a fool. And, and I hate everyone. And the chips are usually sitting in front of Kyle. And yet I do always still feel that pull to get back in the game. Cause it's kind of, it's fun. It's a good place to watch a Laker game, kind of out the side of one eye. And, or Kyle's house. Yeah. Yeah, we should do it again. We should do it again. So, so Jack,
或者就像，该死。如果我只是，你知道我做了什么吗？我没有胆量跟注。为什么我不跟注？我有对Q。它会一直困扰我，我觉得自己像个白痴。然后当我从桌子旁站起来时，就像，好吧，伙计们，希望每个人都玩得开心。当我离开时，我能从他们的眼睛里看到，他们有一种毒药，就像，是的，我们打败了你。我们让你成了傻瓜。而且，我恨每个人。筹码通常都堆在凯尔面前。然而我总是感觉到那种回到游戏中的冲动。因为它有点，很有趣。这是一个看湖人队比赛的好地方，用一只眼睛看。或者凯尔的家。是的。是的，我们应该再做一次。我们应该再做一次。所以，所以杰克，
this one, I don't know. So you started, it says here, if you look on your bio, anybody can look this up. Anybody who's got access to the internet, you, your first thing you did, you did a commercial for a vid game way back in the day, way back in the day. Really? Yeah. What was the inclination? How did that, what was the thing? You grew up in Santa, you were born in Santa Monica, but you grew up a little south of Santa Monica. Permosa beach. Permosa beach. Shout out. What was the moment? Like, what was the thing that you were like, I'm going to go out for this video game commercial? Like, how did you get, how did your path? Well, I'm sure it was just whatever gig was available. You know how it started? Yeah. It started at a Passover Seder. We went over to a friend's house,
这个，我不知道。所以你开始，这里写着，如果你看你的简历，任何人都可以查到。任何有互联网访问权限的人，你，你做的第一件事，你很久以前做了一个视频游戏广告，很久以前。真的吗？是的。动机是什么？那是怎么回事，那件事是什么？你在圣莫尼卡长大，但你在圣莫尼卡南边一点长大。赫莫萨海滩。赫莫萨海滩。大声喊出来。那一刻是什么？就像，是什么让你觉得，我要去参加这个视频游戏广告的试镜？就像，你是怎么得到的，你的路径是怎样的？好吧，我肯定只是任何可用的工作。你知道它是怎么开始的吗？是的。它始于一个逾越节家宴。我们去了朋友家，
family friend, and she was a Holocaust survivor and a really cool lady, mama of the house. And we had our Passover Seder, good Jewish dinden, religious kind of. And then after that, she was like, now it's time for everybody to come to the living room. We're going to play the freeze game. And I said, the freeze game. And I was like eight years old. And it was an improvisational game created by the great Viola Spolan. Jason, I heard you earlier saying yes, Anne. So you're familiar with the dark arts of improvisation. And it's basically just like two people get up on the stage with a living room floor, whatever, what have you. And they'll just start doing a scene. They'll make it up like, okay, we're two butter churners and they'll be churning butter and go,
家庭朋友，她是一位大屠杀幸存者，一个非常酷的女士，家里的妈妈。我们举行了逾越节家宴，很好的犹太晚餐，宗教性质的。然后在那之后，她说，现在是时候让每个人都到客厅来了。我们要玩冻结游戏。我说，冻结游戏。我当时大概八岁。这是一个由伟大的维奥拉·斯波林创造的即兴游戏。杰森，我刚才听到你说“是的，而且”。所以你熟悉即兴表演的黑暗艺术。它基本上就像两个人走上舞台，客厅地板，或者什么，随你便。他们开始表演一个场景。他们会编造它，比如，好的，我们是两个黄油搅拌工，他们会搅拌黄油说，
oh, the churning is so hard. I'm so sweaty. Oh, the sweat is going into the butter. And then anyone in the audience can go freeze. And then they have to stay frozen like they're churning butter. And then you go up and you tap one of them on the shoulder and they leave. And then you take their body position and then you can change it to like, oh, I'm going to murderize the guy. And now you're a boxer who's like punching you. And I played that and I caught the fever so hard because my eight year old like performance instincts kicked in. And I was already kind of a ham class clown. That's what I was going to say. Were you already kind of in that, in that space, like with your friends and at school and shit? Yeah. I mean, I was,
哦，搅拌太难了。我满头大汗。哦，汗水流进了黄油里。然后观众中的任何人都可以喊“冻结”。然后他们必须保持冻结状态，就像他们在搅拌黄油一样。然后你走上去，拍拍其中一个人的肩膀，他们就离开了。然后你采取他们的身体姿势，然后你可以把它改成，比如，哦，我要干掉这家伙。现在你是一个像在打你的拳击手。我玩了那个游戏，我发烧得太厉害了，因为我八岁时的表演本能被激发了。而且我本来就是个爱出风头的小丑。我本来想说这个。你当时已经在那个空间里了吗，就像和你的朋友们在学校里一样？是的。我的意思是，我，
I was starved for laughs. I loved getting yucks. Uh-huh. And it was the sweet manna from heaven. And so, so then my parents divorced. This is, I'm not good at telling stories. No, this is a good thing. I'm so longer than you want to know that you can get into a cry right here. By the way, this is short for Bateman. This is, if you were Bateman, this would be considered short. So go ahead. I don't think I'm going to cry, but my parents divorced. What was that like, Jack? And then, um, I was still kind of like doing stuff. Like I was really into weird Al Yankovic and Hermosa Beach going to school. We would do different songs from, from the Dr. Demento show in front of the classroom, me and some of my friends. And then my, my mom started
我渴望笑声。我喜欢得到笑声。嗯哼。那是来自天堂的甜美吗哪。所以，然后我父母离婚了。这是，我不擅长讲故事。不，这是一件好事。我比你想象的要长，你知道你可以在这里哭出来。顺便说一句，这是贝特曼的缩写。这是，如果你是贝特曼，这会被认为是短的。所以继续吧。我不认为我会哭，但我父母离婚了。那是什么感觉，杰克？然后，嗯，我还在做一些事情。我真的很喜欢“怪人”阿尔·扬科维奇，在赫莫萨海滩上学。我们会在教室前面表演来自德门托博士节目的不同歌曲，我和我的一些朋友。然后我的，我的妈妈开始
dating this, this dude, David Katz, my stepdad. And he was like, a really creative guy. And he's like, Jack, Jack is very talented. He should be doing this. I was like, I do want to do this. I want to be on TV. And there was a kid in my class in Hermosa Beach. I was so jealous of him. He was in a movie called Real Life by the incredible genius known as Albert Brooks. Albert Brooks. Yes. Not Albert Einstein. His real name changed to Brooks. Was Charles Groden in that? Yes. Yes. He played the dad of the family. And the whole family is like, Oh, did he play the dad? No, I don't remember who played who. This isn't a Stiller's favorite movie. I think it might be because it is a great movie. And anyway, so this little punk was in it.
和这个家伙，大卫·卡茨，我的继父约会。他是一个非常有创造力的人。他说，杰克，杰克非常有天赋。他应该做这个。我说，我确实想做这个。我想上电视。我班上有一个孩子在赫莫萨海滩。我非常嫉妒他。他出演了一部电影叫《真实生活》，由那位不可思议的天才阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯执导。阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯。是的。不是阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦。他的真名改成了布鲁克斯。查尔斯·格罗丁在里面吗？是的。是的。他扮演了那个家庭的父亲。整个家庭就像，哦，是他演的父亲吗？不，我不记得谁演谁了。这不是斯蒂勒最喜欢的电影。我想可能是，因为它是一部伟大的电影。总之，这个小混蛋在里面。
This punk was in it. He played the son. He didn't have a big part, but I just was like, Oh, I want what he has. How did he get that to do? How do you do it? And my stepfather thinks it's easy. You go on the auditions, you go and you do. It takes a picture of yourself. And I was like, that, will you take me? And he was like, Yes. No way. And my stepfather drove me around town and I auditioned for all of the commercials and all the things for like a year. I got an agent, the Jack Rose agency. I was at Jack Rose. You were at Jack Rose. I was at Jack Rose. It was also Jack Rose's Dorothy Dayotus. We probably bumped into each other like a hundred times at auditions. Was Dorothy Dayotus also on the door? I don't remember. Did you book right away, Jack?
这个小混蛋在里面。他扮演儿子。他戏份不多，但我当时就想，哦，我想要他拥有的东西。他是怎么做到的？你怎么做到的？我继父认为这很容易。你去试镜，你去表演。拍一张自己的照片。我说，那个，你会带我去吗？他说，是的。没门。我继父开车带我到处跑，我试镜了所有的广告和所有的事情，大概一年。我找了一个经纪人，杰克·罗斯经纪公司。我在杰克·罗斯。你在杰克·罗斯。我也是杰克·罗斯的桃乐丝·戴奥图斯。我们可能在试镜时撞到过一百次。桃乐丝·戴奥图斯也在门口吗？我不记得了。你马上就接到了工作吗，杰克？
No. I went on a few. I booked pretty quick though. It wasn't the first one, but one of the early ones, I was like 12 years old. Yeah. It was the video game commercial you're talking about. It was for Activision for Atari. It was called Pitfall. Yeah. I love that. And I remember the audition. I went in there and I auditioned my ass off and they were like, can you do it like you're really cocky, like you're real cocksure yourself? Not a problem. It was perfect because that's like, that was my go-to acting character thing is being super confident, overconfident. And I just crushed it and I left the audition high. That was the thing. Those auditions, those were like drugs to me because it felt so good to like nail it. It didn't
不。我参加了几个。但我很快就接到了工作。不是第一个，但其中一个早期的，我大概12岁。是的。就是你说的那个视频游戏广告。是为Activision的Atari做的。叫《Pitfall》。是的。我喜欢那个。我记得那次试镜。我走进去，我拼命试镜，他们说，你能表现得像你真的很自大，像你对自己很有把握吗？没问题。这太完美了，因为那就是，那是我的招牌表演角色，就是超级自信，过度自信。我搞定了，我带着兴奋离开了试镜。就是那件事。那些试镜，对我来说就像毒品，因为那种感觉太好了，就像搞定它一样。甚至
even matter if I got the part or not. If I got them laughing, I was like, I love life. You still get that charge, right? When you get a laugh or you're in front of an audience or a camera or something, right? I still get a charge if I feel like a job well done. Yeah. Nice. What about if you make your kids laugh? Is it an audience of one plenty big? Dude, if I can make my kids laugh, that's actually the top of the heap and it's tough. They are a tough audience because I'm so embarrassing to them. That's not true. How old are they now? They're now 13 and 15. Oh, that's a tough audience. Actually, sorry. My boy just had a birthday, 14 and 15. I got a 15-year-old and she just, you got to have, your shit's got to be tight, worked on and bulletproof,
不在乎我是否得到了那个角色。如果我让他们笑了，我就想，我热爱生活。你仍然有那种冲动，对吧？当你得到笑声或者你在观众或摄像机前时，对吧？如果我觉得工作做得好，我仍然会有冲动。是的。不错。如果你让你的孩子们笑呢？一个人的观众够大吗？伙计，如果我能让我的孩子们笑，那实际上是顶峰，而且很难。他们是一个很难对付的观众，因为我让他们感到尴尬。那不是真的。他们现在多大了？他们现在13岁和15岁。哦，那是一个很难对付的观众。其实，抱歉。我的孩子刚过生日，14岁和15岁。我有一个15岁的女儿，她只是，你必须有，你的东西必须紧凑，经过打磨，防弹，
but if you're going to get even a grin out of her, you know, you can't be workshopping material in front of her. Go ahead, Sean. I was just saying, Jason's kid, Maple, I just have to shop and go, hey, and she laughs. Yeah, she's a little bit easier, but she'll get tough. But the 15-year-old audience, but also Sean's the funniest of all of us. Can we just admit it? So Sean's got it. He's also the best host. He's got the nominations to prove it. Oh yeah, he got nominated for best host. Wait, Jack, I want to know. I'm trying to talk over at Sean. This is something you should really revel in. Here's how desperate for last, in Mitchell Roberts and I, the great Mitchell Roberts, great rest development, he and I would be writing stuff and we'd be at his house
但如果你想从她那里得到哪怕一丝微笑，你知道，你不能在她面前研讨材料。继续，肖恩。我只是说，杰森的孩子，梅普尔，我只需要购物然后说，嘿，她就笑了。是的，她稍微容易一点，但她会变得很难对付。但15岁的观众，而且肖恩是我们所有人中最有趣的。我们能承认吗？所以肖恩有这个天赋。他也是最好的主持人。他有提名来证明这一点。哦，是的，他获得了最佳主持人提名。等等，杰克，我想知道。我正试图在肖恩说话时插话。这是你应该真正享受的事情。这是对笑声的渴望，在米切尔·罗伯茨和我，伟大的米切尔·罗伯茨，《发展受阻》，他和我会写东西，我们会在他家
and then he'd be like, we need to go to Starbucks because we'd be in his office writing all day and we just needed to go and do, because we didn't have an audience anymore. We were sick of each other and we thought like the barista or whoever's in line next to us could probably use some exposure to what we got going on. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Jack, I want to ask you about those amazing Instagram things you do because I laugh so fucking hard at those and they seem like they take weeks to film. The fucking production value. The energy and the effort that goes into them. I want to see these. Thank you. They're so funny. Thank you for noticing. Yeah, I mean, you're in your superhero speedos and you're running around like doing superhero things.
然后他会说，我们需要去星巴克，因为我们整天在他的办公室里写作，我们只是需要去，做，因为我们不再有观众了。我们厌倦了彼此，我们认为咖啡师或排在我们后面的人可能需要接触一下我们正在做的事情。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。杰克，我想问你关于那些你做的惊人的Instagram视频，因为我笑得太厉害了，它们看起来像是花了几个星期拍摄的。该死的制作价值。投入其中的能量和努力。我想看这些。谢谢。它们太有趣了。谢谢你的关注。是的，我的意思是，你穿着超级英雄泳裤，跑来跑去像做超级英雄的事情。
Like what goes into those and why do you do them? Is it fun to do it? Well, I was just sort of coming up with things to do during pandemic times. I was going stir crazy like everybody and I had that you know, that hunger that we talked about earlier where I needed attention. And now it's also like two birds with one stone. The world needs a laugh. Let's see if we can cook something up. So I called up my social media guru, Taylor Stevens. Shout out. Shout out. And I said, let's uh, you know what? I'm feeling like I need to do something with this wop dance. The kids are going crazy. It's the latest thing that everyone's trying to do their version of the wop dance. Can you tell Granddad Bateman what that is? The wop dance, it's wet ass pussy. Okay.
就像投入其中的是什么，你为什么要做它们？做这些有趣吗？好吧，我只是在疫情期间想出一些事情做。我像每个人一样快疯了，我有我们之前谈到的那种饥饿感，我需要关注。现在这也像一石二鸟。世界需要笑声。让我们看看能不能搞出点什么。所以我打电话给我的社交媒体大师，泰勒·史蒂文斯。大声喊出来。大声喊出来。我说，让我们，你知道吗？我觉得我需要用这个WAP舞蹈做点什么。孩子们都疯了。这是每个人都在尝试做自己版本的WAP舞蹈的最新事物。你能告诉贝特曼爷爷那是什么吗？WAP舞蹈，是Wet Ass Pussy。好的。
And it was a huge hit. It was a colossal hit. So I got in my speedo and I just had my friend spray me with a garden hose and I did my dance and it got a good Jillian likes and views. And then I was off to the races and I was like, okay, next I'm going to suit up as a Spider-Man because Spider-Man was about to come out. One of those Spider-Man's was coming out or something. There was some reason and I suited up and I did some more dancing and then I just couldn't stop. It was like a runaway freight train. It was so good. Nobody wanted you to stop. It was hysterical. No one is a better performer than you, Jack. No. I mean, what about you closing out the end of High Fidelity? What was that song you sang on the stage? That was uh, I've been really trying. Oh, God.
这是一个巨大的成功。这是一个巨大的成功。所以我穿上我的泳裤，让我的朋友用花园软管喷我，我跳了我的舞，它获得了很好的点击量和观看量。然后我就开始比赛了，我想，好的，接下来我要穿上蜘蛛侠的衣服，因为蜘蛛侠快要上映了。其中一个蜘蛛侠快要上映了或者什么的。有一些原因，我穿上衣服，跳了更多的舞，然后我就停不下来了。就像一列失控的货运火车。太棒了。没人想让你停下来。太歇斯底里了。没有人比你表演得更好，杰克。不。我的意思是，你在《失恋排行榜》结尾的表现呢？你在舞台上唱的那首歌是什么？那是，我一直在努力。哦，天哪。
Let's get it on. I just don't think there's a better performance of any song by any performer than any medium than that. Well, that was my big break, that, that movie. Was it? That was, well, you had done, yeah, so I was going to get into that. So that was your, that was the thing that you had done a bunch of stuff. First of all, I want to kind of get into this a little bit. So backing up, you, you had started, did you engage me doing the Actors Gang? Is that how you guys? Yep. What was the genesis of the Actors Gang? Walk us through that a little bit. Well, the Actors Gang is like a punk rock theater group from Los Angeles in the 80s. They started Tim Robbins, John Cusack, that whole crew. And if you were a young actor in the 80s in LA,
让我们开始吧。我只是不认为有任何表演者在任何媒介中比那更好的歌曲表演。好吧，那是我的重大突破，那部电影。是吗？那是，好吧，你已经做了，是的，所以我正要进入那个话题。所以那是你的，那是你做过的一堆事情。首先，我想稍微深入了解一下。所以退后一步，你，你开始，你参与我做演员帮吗？你们是那样认识的吗？是的。演员帮的起源是什么？带我们了解一下。好吧，演员帮就像80年代来自洛杉矶的朋克摇滚剧团。他们开始于蒂姆·罗宾斯，约翰·库萨克，整个团队。如果你是80年代洛杉矶的年轻演员，
that was the sweet spot. You wanted to be in the Actors Gang. Well, that, that was my feeling anyway. I don't know, Jason, were you even aware of them or care about that world? I was, I stayed away from gangs a lot, but I wasn't a real gang. I mean, there was no violence. It was, they sound pretty hard. Actors Gang sounds like the softest gang. No, I was busy. Improbuted death. I was reading for Golden Grams commercials and Honey Nut Cheerios and whatnot. Yeah. Yeah. But I would have, I would have loved to have gotten, gotten some gang tats on me from the Actors. They were doing a lot of like political theater and, and they had a cool style that they used the, Stanislavski? No, it was, it was Comedia dell'arte, more like. Sure.
那是最佳时机。你想加入演员帮。好吧，那至少是我的感觉。我不知道，杰森，你甚至知道他们或关心那个世界吗？我，我远离帮派，但我不是真正的帮派。我的意思是，没有暴力。它，它们听起来很硬。演员帮听起来像最软的帮派。不，我很忙。即兴表演。我正在为Golden Grahams广告和Honey Nut Cheerios之类的东西试镜。是的。是的。但我本来很想从演员帮那里得到一些帮派纹身。他们做了很多像政治戏剧，而且他们有一种很酷的风格，他们使用，斯坦尼斯拉夫斯基？不，它是，它是即兴喜剧，更像。当然。
You know, they get all made up in the white face and a lot of presentation looking out into the audience. And anyways, I went to see them when I was like 16 years old. I was in high school and I went to see their production of Freaks. And who is in there? Kyle Gass was one of the actors, Ned Bellamy, Lee Ehrenberg, all of the, all the great Actors Gangers. And I was just sort of like a psycho fan of the gang. I wanted in. It was like they were the chili peppers. I just wanted to be in their world. I wanted to be in a production. So I would go to see the shows and then I would hang out and, and I had a connection, a friend of mine, Bob White, who was a teacher at my school, Crossroads High School. Yeah, the professor. He was a technical theater and also a writer for a
你知道，他们都化上白脸妆，有很多向观众展示的表演。总之，我16岁时去看他们。我在上高中，我去看他们的《怪胎》制作。谁在里面？凯尔·加斯是演员之一，内德·贝拉米，李·埃伦伯格，所有伟大的演员帮成员。我只是像帮派的疯狂粉丝。我想加入。就像他们是红辣椒乐队。我只是想进入他们的世界。我想参加制作。所以我去看演出，然后我会闲逛，而且我有一个联系人，我的一个朋友，鲍勃·怀特，他是我学校十字路口高中的老师。是的，教授。他是技术戏剧，也是演员帮很多节目的编剧。等等，等等，等等，杰克，杰克，应该指出教授，鲍勃·怀特，也是我们扑克游戏的一部分。我们都认识鲍勃。是的，教授，他自己也是一个很大的筹码收藏家。是的，非常大。所以他让我参加了一个叫《大秀》的节目。然后我在爱丁堡戏剧节时又在《Carnage》中得到了另一个角色。哇。事情进展得很顺利。然后我们把它带到了纽约，带到了乔·帕普公共剧院。来吧。他们在公园里。我们被谋杀了。评论太，评论甚至不重要。那是一篇评论。就像，这个家伙，这个好莱坞小丑，蒂姆·罗宾斯，带着他的好莱坞垃圾来到纽约，试图告诉我这是真正的戏剧。那根本不是逐字逐句
lot of the shows at Actors Gang. Wait, wait, wait, Jack, Jack, it should be noted the professor, Bob White, also part of the, our poker game. We all know Bob. Yes, the professor, a very big chip collector himself. Yeah, very big. So he got me a part in a show called The Big Show. And then I got another part in Carnage when we went to Edinburgh Theater Festival. Whoa. And things were cooking with gas. And then we took it to New York, to the Joe Papps Public Theater. Come on. They're in the park. And we got just murdered. The reviews were so, it didn't even matter the reviews. It was one review. It was like, this guy, this Hollywood schmoo, Tim Robbins, comes to New York with his Hollywood crap and tries to tell me that this is real theater. That's not word for word
的。那是一篇写得很好的，只是砍杀工作。那是一个如此糟糕的评论，以至于我只是笑了。我只是觉得这实际上很搞笑，因为你，如果你要得到一个糟糕的评论，你希望它是史上最糟糕的评论。是的，你希望它写得好。是的。嘿，威尔，在开头你介绍杰克时，关于他父母的事情是真的吗？你编造了很多。我想那是真的，对吧，杰克？我的父母比我有趣得多。它是。不，不，但我的意思是，所有那些，他们是做什么的？我的父母是航空航天工程师。这太疯狂了，他们两个都是。是的。而且我妈妈是一个真正的开拓者，第一批在该领域取得成功并爬上阶梯并踢了很多屁股的女性之一。我真的不明白
at all. It was an expertly written, just hatchet job. And it was such a bad review that I just laughed. I just thought this is actually hilarious because you, if you're going to get a bad review, you want it to be the worst review of all time. Yeah, you want it well written. Yeah. Hey, Will, at the beginning when you introed Jack, was that really true about his parents? You made that a lot. I think that's true, right, Jack? My parents are much more interesting than me. It is. No, no, but I mean, like all that, what were they? My parents were aerospace engineers. That's crazy, both of them. Yeah. And my mom was a real trailblazer, one of the first women to be successful in that field and climb the ladder and kick a lot of ass. I don't really understand
他们做了什么，因为我没有继承他们的数学天赋。但这太神奇了。这太疯狂了。但是的，我妈妈致力于阿波罗任务，特别是阿波罗13号。她负责实际上挽救了一些宇航员生命的中止制导系统。好吧，那太疯狂了。是的，他们本来要死了，除了他们就像，这是什么按钮？朱迪思·科恩中止制导系统按钮。我不知道发生了什么。发生了一些事情，她是他们幸存的原因之一。任务结束后几个月，他们来办公室拜访她，说，只是想谢谢你，科恩夫人，救了我们的命。这太疯狂了。你完全没有想过进入某种科学世界吗？
what they did because I did not inherit their mathematical genius. That's amazing though. That's wild. But yeah, my mom worked on Apollo missions, specifically Apollo 13. She was responsible for the abort guidance system that actually saved some astronauts' lives. Well, that's insane. Yeah, they were going to die, except they were like, what's this button? Judith Cohen abort guidance system button. I don't know what happened. Something happened and she was part of the reason why they survived. And they came and visited her at the office after the whole mission a few months later to say, just wanted to thank you, Mrs. Cohen, for saving our lives. That's crazy. Did you have any desire at all to get into some sort of a science world there?
不。我喜欢科幻小说。我也喜欢。我喜欢它。我为它而活。 《2001太空漫游》。喜欢它。伟大的书。亚瑟·C·克拉克。我确实对天文学和那个世界有迷恋，但我没有，我明白我没有在那个领域真正成功所需的条件。别这么说。好吧，不。例如，我试着读那本《时间简史》。是的。它并不简短。没能读过前10页。它应该更简短。我不明白它。是的。然后我就想，等等，你知道吗？他们把那本书拍成了电影，《时间简史》。我只是看那个。是的。我看不懂那部电影。等等，什么，杰克？你看过《机械姬》吗？
No. I love science fiction. I do, too. I love it. I live for it. 2001 Space Odyssey. Love it. Great book. Arthur C. Clark. I do have a fascination for astronomy and for that world, but I don't, I understand that I don't have what it takes to actually succeed in that field. Don't you say that? Well, no. For instance, I've tried to read that book A Brief History of Time. Yes. It's not so brief. Couldn't make it past the first 10 pages. It should be more brief. I don't understand it. Yeah. And then I was like, wait, you know what? They made a movie out of that book, A Brief History of Time. I'll just watch that. Yeah. I couldn't understand the movie. Wait, what, Jack? Did you see Ex Machina?
《机械姬》。伟大的电影。那不是最好的吗？有史以来最好的电影之一。杰克，你做过科幻小说吗？就像斯坦利·库布里克从坟墓里回来导演的那种。是的。你知道我的意思吗？那是一部伟大的电影。他有很多库布里克式的科幻小说。我会说《勇敢者的游戏》。 《勇敢者的游戏》是科幻小说。那是科幻小说。电视，你知道，听着，你知道，事情发生了。威尔，你还能怎么解释它？我不知道，但没有，但像纯科幻小说，杰克，你做过像，我不知道，也许更多，你想做像外星人类型的东西吗？
Ex Machina. Great movie. Isn't that the best? One of the best movies ever. Jack, have you ever done a science fiction? It's like Stanley Kubrick came back out of the grave and directed that kind of. Yeah. Do you know what I mean? That's a great movie. He had a lot of Kubrick-y science fiction. I would say Jumanji. Jumanji is sound science fiction. That is science fiction. The TV, you know, listen, you know, things happen. How else would you explain it, Will? I don't know, but no, but like a pure science fiction, Jack, have you ever done like something like a, I don't know, it's maybe more to, would you want to do like an aliens-y type thing or
《机械姬》。很棒的电影。那不是最棒的吗？史上最棒的电影之一。杰克，你拍过科幻片吗？感觉就像斯坦利·库布里克从坟墓里爬出来执导的一样。是啊。你明白我的意思吗？那是一部伟大的电影。他有很多库布里克风格的科幻作品。我会说是《勇敢者游戏》。《勇敢者游戏》是硬科幻。那确实是科幻。电视，你知道，听着，你知道，事情发生了。不然你还能怎么解释呢，威尔？我不知道，但不是，我是说那种纯粹的科幻，杰克，你有没有拍过类似，我不知道，也许更偏向，你想拍那种类似《异形》风格的东西吗？
something like that? Would that get you going? Dude, you know, I love aliens. Aliens is a good example of something I feel like I could jump in because it was great science fiction. But then Bill Paxton came in and just crushed that comedic role. Yeah. We're toast, man. Amen. Yeah. That's right. Another great science fiction comedy he was in. Weird science. Weird science. And then he got turned into, he got turned into Jabba the Hutt. That's where Jabba the Hutt started. You know, that's a prequel. Jabba the Hutt. Did you know that? No. Yeah. That's where Jabba the Hutt starts. Weird science. That's where it was. He gets turned into Jabba, and then, you know, thousands of years later, Jabba is up on that planet. That's from, that's
差不多是那样？那样能让你动起来吗？伙计，你知道，我喜欢《异形》。《异形》是一个很好的例子，我觉得我可以参与其中，因为它是一部很棒的科幻电影。但后来比尔·帕克斯顿进来了，他把那个喜剧角色演得太绝了。是啊。我们完蛋了，伙计。阿门。是的。没错。他参演的另一部伟大的科幻喜剧。 《科学怪人》。《科学怪人》。然后他变成了，他变成了贾巴。贾巴就是从那儿开始的。你知道，那是前传。贾巴。你知道吗？不知道。是的。贾巴就是从那儿开始的。《科学怪人》。就是那儿。他变成了贾巴，然后，你知道，几千年后，贾巴就在那个星球上了。那是来自，那是
Star Wars canon. Huh. Yeah. But that is the thing. You want to find that thing where it's science fiction, but it's funny. And sometimes it works. It's kind of rare, though, but one that comes to mind. What was that rad one where they were all actors, but then they... Galaxy Quest. Galaxy Quest. Amazing. Speaking of actors getting into trouble, Tropic Thunder is just, is and will always be one of my favorite movies of all time. It is one of the things one could do today, I would imagine. Yeah. I'm going to say thank you. Yeah, you should. Even though I can't really take credit for it, but I was in it, and I did love being in it. You were a lot in it and a big, big, big part of how great that movie was. But, Jack, everybody knows you have this incredible voice. You know,
《星球大战》的正史。嗯。是的。但这就是重点。你想找到那种既是科幻片，又很有趣的东西。有时候这很管用。不过这挺罕见的，但我能想到一个。那部很棒的电影叫什么来着，里面全是演员，然后他们……《银河追缉令》。《银河追缉令》。太棒了。说到演员惹麻烦， 《热带惊雷》绝对是，而且永远是我最喜欢的电影之一。我想象中，这是今天人们能做的事情之一。是的。我要说谢谢。是的，你应该。虽然我不能真的把功劳归于自己，但我参演了，而且我确实很喜欢参与其中。你参与了很多，而且你是那部电影之所以那么棒的一个非常、非常、非常重要的部分。但是，杰克，大家都知道你有一副不可思议的嗓音。你知道，
you really do have an unbelievable singing voice. What about a musical movie? Has anybody approached you about doing a movie musical? Like, you would have been great into the woods. I got it. Redo Flash Gordon. Yeah. Right? Remember Flash Gordon with the Queen soundtrack of Rock Opera? Yeah. Come on, bro. Oh, man. Yeah, I love that. Love Queen. Love Flash Gordon. Fold it all together. Love to see you. It's got the spandex outfits you like to wear on the gram. The insta. What's it called? I would like to be that character that was like, yeah. He was like, oh, yeah. The dude that looked like he was from Road Warrior. I saw that in the theater. Did you guys see that in the theater? I did. Yeah, we're that old. What was that guy's name? The blonde guy that was
你真的有一副令人难以置信的歌喉。音乐电影怎么样？有人找过你拍音乐电影吗？比如，你在《魔法黑森林》里会很棒。我明白了。重拍《飞侠哥顿》。是的。对吧？还记得有皇后乐队配乐的摇滚歌剧《飞侠哥顿》吗？是的。得了吧，兄弟。哦，天哪。是的，我喜欢那个。喜欢皇后乐队。喜欢《飞侠哥顿》。把它们合在一起。很想看到你演。它有你喜欢在Instagram上穿的那种氨纶紧身衣。那个叫什么来着。我想成为那个角色，就是那种，是的。他看起来就像是《疯狂的麦克斯》里的人。我在电影院看过那个。你们在电影院看过吗？我看过。是的，我们老了。那家伙叫什么名字？那个金发家伙，他是
Flash Gordon? Oh, yeah. What was that guy? I don't, I think. Wait, Jack, tell me about, I remember reading about you completely tearing your ankle apart on The Last Conan show. You were supposed to do The Last Conan. Yes. What was the bit that made it happen and like, what was the story? All I know is that you hurt your ankle. Okay, so that was a weird one because I was called up to do the final episode of the Conan farewell show, which is an honor. You know, we love us some Conan. You can't say no to something like that because you gotta love Conan and all the years he's been awesome. I was like, yes. But then I immediately started getting nervous. What am I going to do? It's got to be something special. It's got to be super funny. And they came up with a really
《飞侠哥顿》？哦，是的。那家伙是谁？我不，我想。等等，杰克，告诉我，我记得读到过你在《柯南秀》最后一期节目里彻底撕裂了脚踝。你本该参加最后一期《柯南秀》的。是的。是什么桥段导致了这种情况，故事是怎样的？我只知道你伤了脚踝。好吧，那是一个奇怪的经历，因为我被邀请参加《柯南》告别秀的最后一集，这是一种荣幸。你知道，我们都很喜欢柯南。你不能拒绝这样的事情，因为你必须热爱柯南以及他多年来所做的一切出色工作。我当时想，好的。但我立刻开始紧张起来。我要做什么？必须得是特别的东西。必须得超级搞笑。他们想出了一个非常
funny idea. I thought where I come out, I'm singing a song to Conan. I'm getting really into it. I'm getting physical. I'm taking off my clothes. And then I injure myself. I like, my Achilles. And I go down and then paramedics come and they take me out. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh, God. This is all the bed. And they take me out to the ambulance. And then I say, no, stop the ambulance. And I burst out of the back doors and I come running back. I can't let you down Conan. And I come back in, I burst in and the crowd roars and I finished the song. And it was going to be great. But then when we were doing a pre-tape, because you can't do all of that live, you have to have the you have to cut the carrying me out to the ambulance and the running back into the theater
搞笑的点子。我想的是我出场，给柯南唱首歌。我全身心投入。我变得很活跃。我脱掉衣服。然后我受伤了。我，我的跟腱。我倒下了，然后医护人员来了，把我抬走。对不起。对不起。哦，天哪。这全都在床上。他们把我抬到救护车上。然后我说，不，停下救护车。我从后门冲出来，跑了回来。我不能让你失望，柯南。我跑回来，我冲进去，人群欢呼，我唱完了那首歌。这本来会很棒。但当我们进行预录时，因为你不可能现场完成所有这些，你必须得有，你必须剪掉把我抬上救护车和跑回剧院的镜头
done the day before. Right. The rest of it would be live though. That's right. So on the running out of the ambulance back into Largo Theater, I stepped, I was running with some like funny shoes and you blew a tire in my speedo. So it was already really humiliating. I stepped on like an uneven piece of sidewalk and they even had to tape there to let idiots know, be careful because it's uneven here. And I rolled the ankle and I heard a pop and I was like, and I went down for real. And it was so surreal because it was so much like what the bit we were going to do. Yeah, it's very meta. I injured myself doing the bit. And they thought you were still doing the bit? No, they knew that's not where he's supposed to. Conan came running out and everyone was like, oh
前一天就拍好了。没错。剩下的部分是现场直播。没错。所以在从救护车跑回拉戈剧院的过程中，我踩到了，我穿着一些滑稽的鞋子在跑，我的泳裤爆胎了。所以这已经非常丢人了。我踩到了一块不平的人行道，他们甚至还在那里贴了胶带，提醒白痴们小心，因为这里不平。我扭伤了脚踝，我听到了一声脆响，我当时想，然后我真的倒下了。这太超现实了，因为它和我们要演的桥段太像了。是的，非常元叙事。我演那个桥段时真的受伤了。他们以为你还在演那个桥段？不，他们知道那不是他该在的地方。柯南跑了出来，每个人都想，哦
God. And he tripped. The crew tripped. Yeah. And then the people, Conan was like, there's the ambulance. Come on guys, come out and they're like, we're not paramedics, we're actors. We were hired. We move on background. Is this a cut? Are we cutting? Are we in grace right now? We're in lunch. There was a lot of confusion. Someone made a quick run to get me some ice. I got the MRI and it was definitely wrecked. And they were like, yeah, you're going to have to take a few months off. And I was like, how long did it take to heal? I mean, to be honest with you, it's still not a hondo percent. Right. I don't know if it'll ever be like obviously still in litigation, Sean. Yeah. What is the number you're seeking from Conan Produce? It still hurts. I get it.
天哪。然后他绊倒了。工作人员绊倒了。是的。然后人们，柯南说，救护车在那儿。快点伙计们，出来，他们说，我们不是医护人员，我们是演员。我们被雇来的。我们是背景演员。这是剪辑吗？我们要剪掉吗？我们现在在休息吗？我们在吃午饭。当时非常混乱。有人赶紧跑去给我拿冰块。我做了核磁共振，它确实彻底废了。他们说，是的，你得休息几个月。我当时想，需要多久才能痊愈？老实说，还没完全好。没错。我不知道它是否会，显然还在诉讼中，肖恩。是的。你向柯南制作组索赔的金额是多少？还是很疼。我明白。
It's part of the one of the risks of the game. I don't want to go suing. I don't think I am a lawyer. I would bury Conan in lawyers. Was the appearance still kind of somewhat salvaged? Yes. So I say to the doctor later that day, but can I go and just sing? He's like, yeah, you can't dance. You can't do any of the physical stuff you're going to do. But you can sing just to wear the boot. So I wore the boot and I showed up and it was very heroic. I actually ended up being, I think, better than what it was going to be. Did they show the part of you rolling the ankle as part of the pit? No. Oh, they showed up. But we talked about it. Now, talk to me about those kids. Now, those kids are at 14 and 15, speaking from my own experience, as early as this morning,
这是游戏风险的一部分。我不想去起诉。我不认为我是个律师。我会用律师把柯南淹没。那次出场还算挽救回来了吗？是的。所以我那天晚些时候对医生说，但我能去唱歌吗？他说，是的，你不能跳舞。你不能做任何你要做的体力活。但你可以唱歌，只要穿上护具就行。所以我穿上了护具，我出现了，这非常英勇。我实际上最终觉得，比原计划的还要好。他们把你在那个桥段里扭伤脚踝的部分播出来了吗？没有。哦，他们播出来了。但我们谈论过它。现在，跟我说说那些孩子。现在，那些孩子14岁和15岁了，从我自己的经验来看，就在今天早上，
I was talking to my 15-year-old about next year, we got to start looking at colleges. Are you prepared? Are you and the baby mama prepared for the empty nesting that's going to start? No. I'm not going to do well with that. I know it. Have you already started separating from your children just to preserve your own emotional well-being? I've already started atrophying all of my love and affection for my children because I'm trying to protect myself. That's how you do it, right? Atrophy the love. Yeah, that's how he thinks. He did that at birth, right? When you were in the labor. Well, I picked up the kid, I cut the cord, I gave him a little piece of labor. He was like, these kids are going to leave me. Like everything else in my life,
我还在和我的15岁孩子谈论明年，我们得开始考虑大学了。你准备好了吗？你和孩子他妈准备好迎接即将开始的空巢生活了吗？没有。我处理不好那个。我知道。你已经开始为了保持自己的心理健康而疏远你的孩子了吗？我已经开始让所有对孩子的爱和感情萎缩了，因为我在试图保护自己。这就是你的做法，对吧？让爱萎缩。是的，他就是这么想的。他在出生时就这么做了，对吧？当你在分娩时。好吧，我抱起孩子，剪断脐带，我给了他一点分娩的痛苦。他当时想，这些孩子会离开我。就像我生命中的一切一样，
it's going to leave me. I've got to start pulling away now. I think we are trying to do the opposite. We're jonesing for the time like three years ago when they loved us way more. But once they hit those teen years, that separation, they're taking care of that. They're taking care of the atrophy. They're like, oh, you guys are so embarrassing. Just stay away from us. I don't want to talk to you. Right. It's part of their growing up is to emancipate themselves from their parents. Yeah. You know, they're doing well. I'm glad they like going to school because I was the worst and I thought if they take after me, they're going to sleep through school. Did you do any additional voluntary school, college? I did some Hebrew school, but it wasn't really voluntary. My parents
它会离开我。我现在得开始疏远了。我想我们正试图做相反的事情。我们渴望三年前他们更爱我们的时光。但一旦他们到了十几岁，那种疏离感，他们自己会处理。他们正在处理那种萎缩。他们会说，哦，你们太尴尬了。离我们远点。我不想和你说话。没错。这是他们成长的一部分，就是从父母身边独立出来。是的。你知道，他们做得很好。我很高兴他们喜欢上学，因为我以前是最差的，我想如果他们像我一样，他们会在学校里睡大觉。你参加过任何额外的志愿学校、大学吗？我上过希伯来学校，但那不是自愿的。我父母
forced me to do it until I got my bar mitzvah at 13. I was like, I'm done. And they're like, no, but you can continue to study. No. Yeah. So there was no college for you. I went to UCLA. And I was a theater major and I was there for like a year and a half, but really just because my dad wanted me to get a degree. And I dropped out and I ran away with the actor's gang. Dude, UCLA is not an invite. They just throw out. No, it's tough. You probably had some good numbers getting in there. It was very competitive, but yeah, I had some decent numbers. It wasn't as competitive as it is now. In 89, 88, 89, you could get in there with, you didn't need straight A's. And maybe I pulled a couple strings. Maybe I got a little help. How excited was David Katz
强迫我上，直到我13岁举行受戒礼。我当时想，我受够了。他们说，不，但你可以继续学习。不。是的。所以你没上大学。我去了加州大学洛杉矶分校。我是戏剧专业的，我在那儿待了一年半，但其实只是因为我爸爸想让我拿个学位。我退学了，然后和演员帮一起跑了。伙计，加州大学洛杉矶分校不是随便就能进的。他们只是扔出。不，很难。你进去的时候可能分数不错。竞争非常激烈，但是的，我有一些不错的分数。当时没现在这么激烈。在89年、88年、89年，你可以进去，你不需要全A。也许我动用了一些关系。也许我得到了一点帮助。大卫·卡茨有多兴奋
that he was proved right? This is the talent scout, David Katz, aka your stepdad. How stoked was he when it really started to pan out was he's just like, look how good young Jack is doing. Yes. But also what was your relationship like? What an awesome thing that he encouraged you. Yes. Recognize that that was something that was a positive. Yes. And he encouraged you. And then you really made it your life. And how did that affect your relationship with him? All that stuff. Yeah, very proud. And definitely has been a great touchstone and person to talk to all throughout my career, just to share with him like, well, now this is happening. And oh, I got an audition for this. And you know, I'll ask him his advice and he gets a kick out of it. And he also writes,
他被证明是对的？这就是那个星探，大卫·卡茨，也就是你的继父。当事情真的有了起色时，他有多激动，他是不是就像，看看年轻的杰克做得多好。是的。但你们的关系怎么样？他鼓励你真是太棒了。是的。认识到那是一件积极的事情。是的。他鼓励了你。然后你真的把它变成了你的生活。那对你和他的关系有什么影响？所有这些事情。是的，非常自豪。而且在我整个职业生涯中，他绝对是一个很好的试金石和倾诉对象，只是和他分享，比如，现在发生了这个。哦，我得到了这个试镜机会。你知道，我会问他的建议，他从中得到了乐趣。而且他也写，
you know, he wants to get that going too. And I feel like, God, he got me going. I got to get him going. I got him to write a sci-fi thing. You know what's funny? You say that because my dad in the last couple of years, during the pandemic, my dad wrote a book and a great book. What's the name of it, Willie? It's called Bean Fate. And it just came out in Canada. What's it called? Bean, like a bean, like a jelly bean fate. It's a play on a word of BFA and whatever, bunch of things, but it's French. But it's not a French book, but he wrote it. It's based on a true story and about these, these sort of guys, you know, in the liquor business during prohibition and stuff. And it's a sort of like a based on true events. My dad wrote a book over the pandemic.
你知道，他也想把那个搞起来。我觉得，天哪，是他让我开始的。我也得让他开始。我让他写了一个科幻的东西。你知道什么很有趣吗？你这么说，因为我爸爸在过去几年里，在疫情期间，我爸爸写了一本书，一本很棒的书。书名是什么，威利？它叫《豆子命运》。它刚在加拿大出版。叫什么？豆子，像一颗豆子，像一颗果冻豆的命运。这是BFA的一个双关语，还有其他很多东西，但它是法语。但它不是一本法语书，但他写了它。它是基于一个真实的故事，关于这些，这些家伙，你知道，禁酒令期间从事酒类生意的人之类的。这是一种基于真实事件的东西。我爸爸在疫情期间写了一本书。
It was called I'm out of here. For real? No. Well, well, sorry, go ahead. It's okay. We'll can cut that out. Thanks, Sean. I'm going to talk to you. Just you have an extra time after the session. But I'm really proud of my dad. He wrote this book. And in the same way, I'm really psyched that he did that at this age. You know, he's, he's getting on and that is amazing. He actually did it and he found a publisher and he just got published and, and it's pretty cool. And I think that I'm sure in the same way you feel that about David, like they're wanting to encourage him to, I think it's pretty, pretty rad. Yeah. Well, he's super creative and funny too. I think he's a real character. You could tell by my impersonation of him earlier that he's got, he's got some magic
书名叫《我要走了》。真的吗？不。好吧，好吧，抱歉，你继续。没关系。我们可以把那段剪掉。谢谢，肖恩。我要和你谈谈。你会议结束后有额外的时间。但我真的为我爸爸感到骄傲。他写了这本书。同样地，我真的很兴奋他在这个年纪做了这件事。你知道，他，他年纪大了，这太神奇了。他真的做到了，他找到了出版商，他刚刚出版了，这真的很酷。我相信你对大卫也有同样的感觉，就像他们想鼓励他一样，我觉得这非常、非常棒。是的。嗯，他超级有创意，也很有趣。我觉得他是个真正有个性的人。你可以从我刚才模仿他的样子看出他有一些魔法
sauce. And I actually tried to get him going. He had an idea because he loves to Uber and all through pandemic times, he was Ubering everywhere. And I got him an Uber account. So I'm like, go crazy. Do it. Excel Uber. What a son. And he does the, and he says, I hate it. I was like, I had, I had the most incredible conversation with this, this, this painter. And I was like, this is great. And he's like, I have an idea for an Uber. I should do an Uber commercial. And I was like, I'm on it. And so we went and we directed, we, we got cameras. We got some Uber drivers that he became friends with and we put like cameras in the Ubers and, and had him go all around town. No way. In Ubers and like just talking with people and having conversations.
酱汁。我其实试着让他开始。他有一个想法，因为他喜欢开优步，在整个疫情期间，他到处都在开优步。我给他弄了一个优步账户。所以我说，去疯狂吧。去做吧。优步精英。真是个好儿子。他做到了，他说，我讨厌它。我说，我和这个，这个，这个画家进行了最不可思议的谈话。我说，这太棒了。他说，我有一个关于优步的想法。我应该拍一个优步广告。我说，我这就去办。所以我们去了，我们导演了，我们，我们弄到了摄像机。我们找了一些他结识的优步司机，我们在优步车里装了摄像机，让他绕着城里转。不会吧。在优步车里，就像和人们聊天，进行对话。
And I swear it was the funniest little thing. It was called come Uber with me. And you would get in the Uber with David Katzen. Did Uber see this? It was one of the funniest. Well, of course, that was the whole point. We were going to make this and we sent it to Uber. And they were like, hard pass. We're not going to do this. And also you're not allowed to show this to anyone. Oh, wow. No way. Wow. I was kind of lame. But I felt like they were being so short-sighted because they, they needed at the time, like a little humanistic, humanizing business. But for whatever reason, you know, David, when he talks with people, he doesn't really have a filter and he'll say some inappropriate things, but that's where the funny comedy happens. He says stuff, you know,
我发誓这是最有趣的小东西。它叫《和我一起优步》。你会和戴维·卡茨一起上优步。优步看到这个了吗？这是最有趣的之一。嗯，当然，这就是重点。我们打算制作这个，我们把它发给了优步。他们说，坚决拒绝。我们不会做这个。而且你也不允许给任何人看。哦，哇。不会吧。哇。我当时觉得这有点烂。但我感觉他们太短视了，因为他们，他们在当时需要一点人文主义的、人性化的商业。但不管什么原因，你知道，大卫，当他和人交谈时，他真的没有过滤，他会说一些不恰当的话，但这就是有趣的喜剧发生的地方。他说一些东西，你知道，
that maybe culturally he'll cross boundaries. You're not supposed to talk about things with people. But I think that he's a super star. What was that show, Taxicab Confessions? Yes. Wasn't that, that was on HBO, I think? HBO, yeah, wasn't that great? Yeah. Yeah, why don't they still do that? You know, a friend of mine was on it and he was wasted. And it was him and like two other gay guys in the back seat. And they were cleaning out. They're like, girl, like they were so over the top making fun of every single person in the world. And then they were plowed so drunk and they got out and they go, we're HBO's Taxicab Confessions. Would you sign this release form? And my friend,
可能在文化上他会越界。你不应该和人们谈论某些事情。但我认为他是一个超级明星。那个节目叫什么来着，《出租车忏悔录》？是的。那不是，那是在HBO播的，我想？HBO，是的，那不是很好吗？是的。是的，为什么他们现在还不做那个？你知道，我的一个朋友上过那个节目，他喝醉了。那是他和另外两个同性恋在后座。他们正在清理。他们就像，女孩，就像他们太夸张了，嘲笑世界上每一个人。然后他们喝得烂醉，他们下车说，我们是HBO的《出租车忏悔录》。你能签这份免责声明吗？我的朋友，
even though he was plowed drunk, had to wear it with all to be like, no, I would not sign in that. I would not sign. I was going to ask that question. Like, how did they, do they tell you before you get in or do they tell you after? They must tell you after, yeah. There must be so many great episodes where the drunk person didn't sign the thing. Only incredible episodes would be those, right? Where he's like, oh, no, no, no, no, no. No one's ever going to see that. Dude, didn't Todd Phillips drive a cab on Taxicab Confessions? That sounds familiar. That was one of his early gigs. No. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, that sounds familiar. You know who else? Danny Sullivan used to be a New York
即使他喝得烂醉，也有理智说，不，我不会签那个。我不会签。我正要问那个问题。比如，他们怎么，他们是在你上车前告诉你的，还是事后告诉你的？他们一定是在事后告诉你的，是的。一定有很多很棒的剧集是醉酒的人没签那个东西的。只有不可思议的剧集才会是那些，对吧？他当时想，哦，不，不，不，不，不。没人会看到那个。伙计，托德·菲利普斯是不是在《出租车忏悔录》里开过出租车？这听起来很熟悉。那是他早期的工作之一。不。是的。是的，是的，这听起来很熟悉。你知道还有谁吗？丹尼·沙利文曾经是一名纽约
Taxicab driver. And these people are for Tracy. They are Todd Phillips and Danny Sullivan are director, right? Well, Danny Sullivan was an IndyCar driver, but Todd Phillips was a director. Yes, is a director. Good director. Great director. And now a word from our sponsor. All right, back to the show. Jack, what's coming up for you that you're excited about? Like any projects that you're working on that are... Well, Jack's got this new, I want to say, because he's not going to do his own plug ski, so I'm going to do it. Jack's got this Kung Fu Panda series that's coming. No way. No way. Where? Really? It's going to be on Netflix. Oh, great. Thank you for bringing that up. You're right.
出租车司机。这些人是特雷西。他们是托德·菲利普斯和丹尼·沙利文是导演，对吧？嗯，丹尼·沙利文是印地赛车手，但托德·菲利普斯是导演。是的，是导演。好导演。伟大的导演。现在是赞助商时间。好了，回到节目。杰克，你接下来有什么让你兴奋的事情吗？比如你正在做的任何项目……嗯，杰克有这个新的，我想说，因为他不会自己做广告，所以我来做。杰克有这个即将推出的《功夫熊猫》系列。不会吧。不会吧。在哪儿？真的吗？它会在Netflix上播出。哦，太棒了。谢谢你提到这个。你是对的。
I'm not a real plugger. I've got other people's handkerchiefs, but it's back to the panda. And it's funny because it came up in pandemic times. Panda. Panda. There must be a way to connect those, but... Yeah, voice work works great during the pandemic. That's how this thing got started. Oh, dude. Yeah, no kidding, because I was going through crazy as it's been established. And Netflix was like, hey, we're taking over your old gig, the Kung Fu Panda. And we know that you never do the TV show. They got a sound alike to do that. But would you want to do it now that we're doing it? And I was like, yes, I want it just because I just wanted some like... I wanted some rad pandemic times, like gigs to keep my sanity. Yeah, of course. And do you do it there
我不是一个真正的推销员。我有别人的手帕，但回到熊猫身上。这很有趣，因为它是在疫情期间出现的。熊猫。熊猫。一定有一种方法可以把它们联系起来，但是……是的，配音工作在疫情期间效果很好。这就是这件事开始的方式。哦，伙计。是的，没开玩笑，因为我当时正经历着疯狂，正如已经确定的那样。Netflix说，嘿，我们要接手你的旧工作，《功夫熊猫》。我们知道你从不做电视节目。他们找了一个声音相似的人来做那个。但既然我们正在做，你想做吗？我当时想，是的，我想要，只是因为我只是想要一些……我想要一些很棒的疫情期间的工作来保持理智。是的，当然。你是在那儿做的吗
in the little... In the room you're doing this? Exactly. This is where I do everything, by the way. It's a real boring nondescript background, but this is John Spiker's studio. He's also a tenacious D bass player and does all of our production on our last few albums. No way. And so it sounds so good here. I was like, oh, I just want to do all my interviews here too. It's the best, right? Are you one of those actors? Like, do you panic if you're not working and and then you start maybe writing something and looking for something? Or are you like, good, you know what? I'll wait for it to come. He already answered you, dude. I wouldn't even let you finish. Yes, the panic is real. I think that's an inherent part of being an actor or an
在那个小……在你做这个的房间里？没错。顺便说一下，这就是我做所有事情的地方。这是一个非常无聊、平淡无奇的背景，但这是约翰·斯派克的录音室。他也是Tenacious D的贝斯手，并负责我们最后几张专辑的所有制作。不会吧。所以这里听起来太棒了。我当时想，哦，我只想在这里做我所有的采访。这是最好的，对吧？你是那种演员吗？比如，如果你不工作你会恐慌，然后你开始写点什么，寻找点什么？还是你像，好的，你知道吗？我会等它到来。他已经回答你了，伙计。我甚至没让你说完。是的，恐慌是真实的。我认为这是作为演员或
entertainer. Like, what is the next gig? And all the whole time I'm working on a gig, I'm thinking, God, when is it over? I just want my Google Calendar to be empty. But then once you get there, and the Google Calendar is empty, it's terrifying. Because it's like, wait, I think it might be over. Never goes away. Dude, I do the exact same thing where I just I'm like, I just can I just have like five days where there's nothing to fucking do blah, blah, blah. And then you wake up on that first day of the five and you're like, where's all this stuff? I was like, wait, wait, Jack, I want to ask you because we were talking about HBO before and stuff. How did Tenacious D, the show, how did that start? Obviously, you engage in each other. But what was the genesis of that?
艺人固有的一部分。比如，下一个工作是什么？在整个工作期间，我都在想，天哪，什么时候结束？我只想让我的谷歌日历是空的。但一旦你到了那里，谷歌日历是空的，那就太可怕了。因为就像，等等，我想它可能结束了。永远不会消失。伙计，我做着完全一样的事情，我只是想，我能有五天什么他妈的都不用做吗，等等。然后你在那五天的第一天醒来，你会想，这些东西都在哪儿？我当时想，等等，等等，杰克，我想问你，因为我们之前谈到了HBO之类的。Tenacious D，那个节目，是怎么开始的？显然，你们互相吸引。但那个的起源是什么？
I love the D. Thank you. I just want that as a sound. But I want people to take that me saying I love the D. And the D stands for the D stands for defense. But now it definitely sounds like it stands for dick. Yeah. Love the D defense. Yes, it didn't. No one was saying the D back when we first started Tenacious D. That that wasn't a thing until the late 2000s. Yeah. But anyway, it started, I was in the actors gang. And me and Kyle were both sort of musical people in that world. And, and we sort of started our own splinter group. I just went over to his house all the time. We smoked a bunch of weed and, and jammed. And we're just sort of best friends. And then we were, we wanted to write the best song in the world and call it the best song in the world.
我爱D。谢谢。我只是想要那个作为声音。但我希望人们接受我说的我爱D。D代表D代表防御。但现在它听起来绝对像代表鸡巴。是的，爱D防御。是的，它没有。当我们刚开始Tenacious D时，没人说D。那在2000年代末之前不是一回事。是的。但无论如何，它开始了，我在演员帮。我和凯尔在那个世界里都是音乐人。而且，我们算是组建了自己的分支小组。我只是经常去他家。我们抽了很多大麻，然后即兴演奏。我们算是最好的朋友。然后我们，我们想写世界上最好的歌，并称之为世界上最好的歌。
And we just thought that was so dumb and so funny. And we worked on it for a while and it wasn't quite gelling. The concept was wrong. And then we're like, oh, wait, and it clicked. We forgot the best song in the world. We did write it, but we weren't recording because we're stoners. And we're so mad. But you know, let's just write. So the song is a lament. We forgot. It's a, it's a called a tribute. It's called tribute to the greatest song in the world because we forgot it. And that to this day is still our flagship song. It was like, back when we only had one song and it was tribute, we've been chasing the dragon ever since. Isn't that what the concept of the film was too? Or am I, am I kind of mad? Yes, right? The pick of destiny was, was definitely a greatest song
我们只是觉得那太蠢、太搞笑了。我们研究了一段时间，但不太合拍。概念错了。然后我们想，哦，等等，它点击了。我们忘了世界上最好的歌。我们确实写了，但我们没录音，因为我们是瘾君子。我们太生气了。但你知道，让我们写吧。所以这首歌是一个哀歌。我们忘了。它是一个，它叫致敬。它叫致敬世界上最伟大的歌，因为我们忘了它。直到今天，这仍然是我们最标志性的歌。就像，回到我们只有一首歌的时候，它是致敬，从那以后我们一直在追逐龙。电影的概念不也是这样吗？还是我，我有点疯了？是的，对吧？命运之拨确实是关于世界上最伟大的歌
in the world centric, but that was actually more about Satan's tooth that was turned into a guitar pick. That is my pride. Enjoy that film because that's the only movie I've ever written. And, and even though it was a huge box office bomb, I couldn't have been more proud of it. And I, I did feel like it was the best movie ever made. Is writing the hardest thing you've ever done? It was the most satisfying and most fun. And I, that was the biggest tragedy is that the movie wasn't a huge hit because if it was a huge hit, I would have gone straight into the next thing that I would have written. Right. But yeah. Yeah. But I mean, talk to our buddy, Justin Thoreau, you know, he writes Tropic Thunder and he's, you know, he's not, he's not like dying to write,
为中心，但那实际上更多是关于撒旦的牙齿，它被做成了吉他拨片。那是我的骄傲。享受那部电影，因为那是我写过的唯一一部电影。而且，尽管它在票房上是个巨大的炸弹，但我不能更以此为荣了。而且，我确实觉得它是史上拍得最好的电影。写作是你做过的最难的事情吗？这是最令人满意和最有趣的。而且，我，那是最大的悲剧，电影不是一个巨大的成功，因为如果它是一个巨大的成功，我会直接进入我写的下一件事。没错。但是的。是的。但我的意思是，和我们的哥们贾斯汀·塞洛克斯谈谈，你知道，他写了《热带惊雷》，他，你知道，他不是，他不是那种渴望写
you know, script after script after script, you know, it doesn't automatically just kind of make you Patty Chayevsky. That's true. But you know, we, we, uh, we did that and, um, take your time, man. Yeah. Because now, now I'm lost. Watch this guys. Watch this. I can't even remember where we started. When you were very, well, that was it. That was the first time the first, no, the first time I met tribute. Oh, but, oh, but anyway, we had our one song tribute that we wrote. Yeah. And we went and played our one song, a friend of ours said, Hey, will you come open for me in downtown LA at a little club called Al's Bar. And we're like, yeah, it was a buddy of mine, Steve Moramarko gave us our big break at some like rat infested bar.
你知道，剧本接剧本接剧本，你知道，它不会自动让你成为帕迪·查耶夫斯基。那是真的。但你知道，我们，我们，我们做了那个，而且，嗯，慢慢来，伙计。是的。因为现在，现在我迷路了。看着这个，伙计们。看着这个。我甚至不记得我们从哪儿开始的。当你非常，好吧，就是那个。那是第一次，第一次，不，我第一次见到致敬。哦，但是，哦，但无论如何，我们有我们写的那首致敬歌。是的。我们去演奏了我们那首歌，我们的一个朋友说，嘿，你愿意来洛杉矶市中心的一个叫Al's Bar的小俱乐部为我开场吗？我们说，是的，是我哥们史蒂夫·莫拉马科给了我们大突破，在某个像老鼠出没的酒吧。
And there's 12 people in the audience, but they were kind of cool drunk hipsters and, and we rocked tribute and we rocked so hard, like we put all of our guts into it. And one of the drunk hipsters is the Lord was looking down upon us. David Cross just happened to be there. That's what I thought. And he was like, you guys are really funny, man. Um, I'm David Cross. And, uh, did he hold for applause after he said that? No. I've seen him do that. I'm David Cross. He just is like, um, I have a comedy thing that I'm, I just started with my friend Bob Odenkirk. We do a Mr. Show. Will you guys come down and open for us, play that song? And we're like, yes. And we didn't have any idea who he was.
观众席里有12个人，但他们是那种很酷的喝醉的嬉皮士，而且，我们摇滚了致敬，我们摇滚得太厉害了，就像我们把所有的胆量都投入进去了。其中一个喝醉的嬉皮士是上帝在俯视我们。大卫·克罗斯正好在那儿。我就是这么想的。他就像，你们真的很搞笑，伙计。嗯，我是大卫·克罗斯。而且，他说了那个之后有停顿等待掌声吗？没有。我见过他那样做。我是大卫·克罗斯。他只是像，嗯，我有一个喜剧节目，我刚和我朋友鲍勃·奥登科克开始。我们做《倒霉蛋秀》。你们愿意来为我们开场，演奏那首歌吗？我们说，是的。我们根本不知道他是谁。
And we didn't know about the Ben Stiller show or any of that stuff where he came from. We were just like, we got another gig. It didn't matter what it was. It could have gas up the van. And so that is really what led to the beginning of Tenacious D because Bob and David gave us a sweet slot. And when they went to HBO to do Mr. Show, they brought us along and made us the little appetizer for their show. And that changed everything. And really, that's how I got high fidelity. Then that, that's where school of rock came from. So it's a big, there was a big turning point in my career. Have you sent David a muffin basket or never even sent him? Yeah, nothing. He got nothing in return. But, but now I'm giving him a loving shout out. That's a pretty good,
我们不知道《本·斯蒂勒秀》或任何他出身的东西。我们只是像，我们又得到了一个工作。它是什么并不重要。它能给面包车加满油。所以这确实导致了Tenacious D的开始，因为鲍勃和大卫给了我们一个甜蜜的档期。当他们去HBO做《倒霉蛋秀》时，他们带上了我们，让我们成为他们节目的小开胃菜。那改变了一切。而且真的，这就是我得到《失恋排行榜》的方式。然后那个，那就是《摇滚校园》的来源。所以这是一个大的，我职业生涯的一个大转折点。你给大卫送过松饼篮子吗，还是从来没送过他？是的，什么都没有。他什么回报都没得到。但，但现在我给他一个充满爱的呼喊。那是个相当不错的，
yeah. They're with Hermosa Beach and Hankies. Yeah. But, but this is like, this is like, but it goes to show how fucking small all that, how connected David sees you. He's drunk at a bar. David being drunk at a bar is not that odd. But, but, but David, he's at a bar. He sees you, brings you with Bob to do the thing. And then you end up, and he had worked on the Ben Stiller show. And then years later, you and Ben worked together a bunch to do with the first thing I met you on was when you did envy with Amy and Ben back in 2001, I think or two or some shit like that. Like, and all those dots just connect. Everything is so, it's so small and connected. It's wild. Yeah. Like if, if anybody ever asked me, like, you know, about my sister last, like,
是的。他们和赫莫萨海滩和手帕在一起。是的。但，但这是像，这是像，但这表明了所有那些他妈的有多小，大卫看你有多紧密。他在酒吧喝醉了。大卫在酒吧喝醉并不奇怪。但，但，但大卫，他在酒吧。他看到你，带你和鲍勃去做那个事情。然后你最终，而且他曾在《本·斯蒂勒秀》工作过。然后几年后，你和本一起工作了很多次，做我见到你的第一件事是当你们在2001年和艾米和本一起做《偷拍》时，我想或者是两年前之类的。就像，所有那些点都连在一起了。一切都太，它太小且紧密相连了。这太疯狂了。是的。就像如果，如果有人问我，比如，你知道，关于我姐姐最后，比如，
I have this, my daughter has a friend, what advice would you give them advice for all these young people trying to break into the business or actors? It's just like, go and play the bar down too. Oh, Al's. Play Al's. Al's as much as you can. No, no, just get out there and just do it. You got to just constantly be out there. Like, right? You were, you were so young. How old were you when that happened? 23, 24, our first show. But no, Al's bar was later. I was 27 when we played. It's something like that. 26, 27. I don't know. It's tragic how it's how arbitrary it is, you know, for any of us. I mean, you can think back to the start of, you know, and it's, if we were in the wrong place at that right time, it would have taken longer or maybe not at all. And you
我有一个，我女儿有一个朋友，你会给他们什么建议，给所有这些试图进入这个行业或演员的年轻人的建议？就像，去酒吧演奏吧。哦，Al's。演奏Al's。尽可能多地演奏Al's。不，不，只是走出去，去做吧。你必须不断地走出去。比如，对吧？你，你太年轻了。那发生时你多大？23，24，我们的第一场演出。但没有，Al's Bar是后来。我们演奏时我27岁。差不多是那样。26，27。我不知道。这太悲剧了，它是多么随意，你知道，对我们任何人来说。我的意思是，你可以回想一下开始，你知道，而且，如果我们是在错误的时间出现在错误的地方，那会花更长的时间，或者可能根本不会发生。而且你
think about all the talented friends that we have that just don't, they have not found that moment of access, you know? Are people championing you? Like, whether it's David seeing you or David Katz, you know, seeing you, seeing that and recognizing that your kid who's got talent, like. No, as I said, the Chris Pratt episode, he was a waiter at the bubblegum shrimp thing in Maui, some casting director or whatever. Casting director saw him there and he was like popcorn shrimp, barbecue shrimp, broiled shrimp, baked shrimp, shrimp gumbo, shrimp of this big. That's an old fashioned Hollywood discovery story. You don't hear those very often. No. The ones that take place at Bubba Shrimp. The casting director just walking into Bubba Gumbo Shrimp. Right. Isn't that the
想到我们拥有的所有有才华的朋友，他们只是没有，他们还没有找到那个进入的时刻，你知道？有人在支持你吗？比如，无论是大卫看到你，还是大卫·卡茨，你知道，看到你，看到那个并认识到你的孩子是有天赋的，比如。不，正如我所说，克里斯·帕拉特那一集，他是毛伊岛阿甘虾餐厅的服务员，某个选角导演之类的。选角导演在那里看到了他，他就像爆米花虾、烧烤虾、烤虾、烘焙虾、虾浓汤、这么大的虾。那是一个老派的好莱坞发现故事。你不会经常听到那些。不。那些发生在阿甘虾餐厅的故事。选角导演只是走进阿甘虾餐厅。对吧。那不是
craziest? It's so, so insane and the likelihood of them having mashed shrimp or shrimp casserole. Oh, there goes Sean again. He loves a good food joke. Oh God, he got this slide right next to the mic today. That's carrot top. Oh, he's got it right next to him today. What else is in the chest, Sean? You guys should do, Sean, I was just thinking that you and Jack should do, because you both are such musical dudes. Anything. We'll do anything. I'd love to see you guys jam out on a musical comedy. Let's do it. That would be fun. That would be cool. Let's do a little, we'll do a, call your Instagram friend up and we'll do like a 10 second or 15 second little musical. Sean just finished this play, Jack. He's going to Broadway soon and he's playing Oscar Levant and
最疯狂的吗？这太，太疯狂了，他们有捣碎虾或虾砂锅的可能性。哦，肖恩又来了。他喜欢好的食物笑话。哦，天哪，他今天就在麦克风旁边放了这个幻灯片。那是胡萝卜头。哦，他今天把它放在他旁边了。胸部里还有什么，肖恩？你们应该做，肖恩，我刚才在想，你和杰克应该做，因为你们俩都是音乐达人。任何事。我们会做任何事。我很想看到你们在音乐喜剧上即兴演奏。让我们做吧。那会很有趣。那会很酷。让我们做一个小的，我们叫上你的Instagram朋友，我们会做一个10秒或15秒的小音乐。肖恩刚完成了这部戏，杰克。他很快就要去百老汇了，他正在扮演奥斯卡·黎凡特，而且
he, to rave reviews, by the way. Thank you. That's really very nice. And it's a play, but he also plays a piano on stage. He's a classically trained pianist. Whoa, true story. Yeah, he knows how to do it all. What's it called? Oscar Levant? It's called Good Night Oscar and it's going to the Broadway. Who wrote that? Doug Wright. He's an amazing Pulitzer Prize winning writer. He actually wrote a movie that's being shot right now with Jamie Foxx and Tommy Lee Jones. Whoa. I just went and saw a play on Broadway. I saw Hugh Jackman and the Music Man. How was it? I want to see that. He was great and it was great and I was really jealous because I always thought that would be my play on Broadway. Okay, so but why, why wouldn't you do it? You have the voice, you have the
他，顺便说一下，获得了好评。谢谢。那真的非常好。这是一部戏，但他也在舞台上弹钢琴。他是一位受过古典训练的钢琴家。哇，真实故事。是的，他知道怎么做这一切。它叫什么？奥斯卡·黎凡特？它叫《晚安奥斯卡》，它要去百老汇。谁写的？道格·赖特。他是一位了不起的普利策奖获奖作家。他实际上写了一部电影，现在正在和杰米·福克斯和汤米·李·琼斯一起拍摄。哇。我刚去百老汇看了一部戏。我看了休·杰克曼和《音乐人》。怎么样？我想看那个。他很棒，而且它很棒，而且我很嫉妒，因为我一直认为那会是我在百老汇的戏。好吧，所以但是为什么，为什么你不做呢？你有声音，你有
stamina. Can you imagine if you were going to see Hugh Jackman and the Music Man there had to do a special announcement. Hugh has come down with COVID. Tonight's performance will be by almost as good, Jack Black. Oh, we got trouble, my friend. Well, we got trouble right here in River City. I'm an enormous Hugh Jackman fan, but let me tell you something. I would love to see you play the Music Man. Yeah. I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna say I'd be better than him, but I would bring some different things. What about Joseph? What's the Technicolor Dreamcoat? Yeah, or Jesus Christ Superstar for that. Yes, Judas. That's the original rock opera. Yeah. A lot of people say, oh, it was Tommy by the Who, but really, Jesus Christ Superstar, I think was first and it was, it was a hard
耐力。你能想象如果你去看休·杰克曼和《音乐人》，那里不得不做一个特别公告。休得了新冠。今晚的表演将由差不多一样好的，杰克·布莱克来表演。哦，我们有麻烦了，我的朋友。好吧，我们在河城有麻烦了。我是休·杰克曼的超级粉丝，但我告诉你一件事。我很想看你演《音乐人》。是的。我不会，我不会说我会比他更好，但我会带来一些不同的东西。约瑟夫怎么样？什么是彩色梦幻衣？是的，或者为此《万世巨星》。是的，犹大。那是最初的摇滚歌剧。是的。很多人说，哦，那是The Who的《汤米》，但实际上，《万世巨星》，我想是第一个，而且它是，它是硬
rock. JC, dude, go a ridge. Wait, Jack, I would be, I would be in the pit playing in the little orchestra, tiny orchestra pit at this dinner theater. And when, when you got to the last song, which was Jesus Christ Superstar, right? And I'd be, I'd have to, I would be playing the piano and they'd be like, the director was like, you know, you can just riff, like just riff on the piano, like bang, go nuts, like rock. And I was like, okay, but I only knew how to riff in classical because I was classical, boy. So it was so rinky-dink, like Jesus Christ, if I could take a superstar, if I could take a hoodoo. Oh, I bet it was great. It was so embarrassingly bad. I know what he's talking about too, the riff, because on the, on the Broadway album, the original Broadway album,
摇滚。JC，伙计，去山脊。等等，杰克，我会，我会坐在那个晚餐剧院的小管弦乐队，微小的管弦乐队坑里演奏。而且当，当你唱到最后一首歌时，那是《万世巨星》，对吧？而且我会，我得，我会弹钢琴，他们会像，导演就像，你知道，你可以即兴演奏，就像在钢琴上即兴演奏，比如砰，发疯，像摇滚。我当时想，好的，但我只知道怎么在古典乐里即兴演奏，因为我是古典男孩。所以它太蹩脚了，就像万世巨星，如果我能带一个超级巨星，如果我能带一个巫毒。哦，我敢打赌那很棒。它太尴尬地糟糕了。我也知道他在说什么，那个即兴演奏，因为在百老汇专辑上，最初的百老汇专辑，
whoever was playing piano was going off on that. Yeah, it's cool. I remember coming over, Jack, I came over to the house a couple of years ago with the boys and you were doing, you're doing your ice bath and you're doing the arctic plunge. Yes. Right. And then we went downstairs and you and the boys rocked out in your basement and Jack's got headphones in there so you don't, he doesn't blow everybody's ear. Yeah, the drums get loud down there. Do they play instruments or kids? Yeah. Sammy, my 15-year-old, has sort of lost interest in it, but now the 13-year-old Tommy, actually just turned 14, he's drumming obsessively. Oh, I really like the drums. Almost too much to where I get concerned, but I'm also just like, good, get obsessed. Yeah. Do play too
无论谁在弹钢琴都在上面发疯。是的，这很酷。我记得我过来，杰克，我几年前带着孩子们过来，你正在做，你正在做你的冰浴，你正在做北极潜水。是的。对吧。然后我们下楼，你和孩子们在你的地下室里摇滚，杰克在那里戴着耳机，所以你不会，他不会炸掉每个人的耳朵。是的，鼓声在那里很大。他们玩乐器吗，孩子们？是的。萨米，我的15岁孩子，有点失去了兴趣，但现在13岁的汤米，其实刚满14岁，他痴迷地打鼓。哦，我真的很喜欢鼓。几乎太多了，以至于我感到担心，但我也是就像，好的，去痴迷吧。是的。玩太多
much. Do you have them on the electric drums? Dude. Do you have them on the electric drums with the headphones? I spoil them. He's got an electric drum set in his room. He's got the real drum set in the basement because you really can't have a real drum set if you don't have a basement. You have to have an underground soundproof shelter. Getting back to the ice plunge though, Willie, that's something that you do and it's something that I've never understood because I feel like there's got to be damage going on when you drop your bits and pieces in the ice. Jack does it. He keeps the hot tub hot and then he keeps the pool icy cold, right, Jack? Just never heat the pool. It'll get cold enough. I don't want to go in anything cold. I know, Jack. I do the ice. I have
吗。你有让他们用电子鼓吗？伙计。你有让他们用带耳机的电子鼓吗？我宠坏了他们。他在房间里有一套电子鼓。他在地下室有一套真正的鼓，因为如果你没有地下室，你真的不能有一套真正的鼓。你必须有一个地下隔音避难所。回到冰潜水，威利，那是你做的事情，这是我从未理解的事情，因为我觉得当你把你的零件掉进冰里时，一定会有损坏。杰克做了。他保持热水浴缸很热，然后他保持游泳池冰冷，对吧，杰克？只是永远不要加热游泳池。它会变得足够冷。我不想去任何冷的地方。我知道，杰克。我做冰。我有
an ice, not ice. I have a cold plunge pool. So it gets even colder than not heating the pool in the winter. Yeah. I get it to like 39 degrees and then I got one degree above freezing. Basically. And then I got the sauna. So I heat up and then I just feel like there's got to be damage going on. The body can't like that kind of shock. Kevin Hart does that cold as balls show. What's that? Where he's in the cold part? It's an interview show where he only interviews people while they're soaking in an ice tub. Is that right? I should do that. I've heard that ice plunge actually is great for anxiety. Yeah. Really? You know what? Here's the other thing. Most, like, anxiety meant all the lot of stuff, but also a lot of physical elements
一个冷水池。所以它变得比冬天不加热游泳池更冷。是的。我把它弄到39度左右，然后我比冰点高一度。基本上。然后我有桑拿。所以我加热，然后我只是觉得一定会有损坏。身体不能喜欢那种冲击。凯文·哈特做了那个冷球节目。那是什么？他在冷的部分？这是一个采访节目，他只在人们浸泡在冰桶里时采访他们。是这样吗？我应该做那个。我听说冰潜水实际上对焦虑症很好。是的。真的吗？你知道吗？这是另一件事。大多数，比如，焦虑意味着很多东西，但也很多身体元素
including, and I'm not saying it's a cure for cancer or anything, but all that stuff, it has to do with inflammation and that cold water reduces inflammation, man. It's so good for you. But don't you think it would be healthier and more safe if you did it slowly? Like, if you just started with room temperature water and you slowly, like a frog in a boiling pot of water, that whatever that saying is, but like, I just think the shock of going in there, isn't there a risk of heart attack? That kind of stress? No. I hear you. No. Like a true American, I'm going to wait for the pill to reduce my inflammation. Yes. That's, you know what it is? It's called Advil. They got it. Yeah. Got it.
包括——我不是说它能治愈癌症什么的——但所有这些东西都与炎症有关，而冷水可以减轻炎症，伙计。这对你真的很有好处。但你不觉得如果你慢慢来会更健康、更安全吗？比如，如果你从室温水开始，慢慢地，就像温水煮青蛙那样——不管那句谚语怎么说——但我只是觉得突然跳进去的冲击力，难道没有心脏病发作的风险吗？那种压力？不。我明白你的意思。不。就像一个真正的美国人，我会等着吃药来减轻我的炎症。是的。你知道那是什么吗？那叫Advil。他们有那个。是的。明白了。
Jack, we've taken up way too much of your time, man. Yes, that is. I love it. It's been so great having you. What a dear man. You're the best. Hey, you know, when I first heard you guys, I was like, oh, shit, I should try and get on that show. But then I realized I don't like to do shows because I get too nervous for shows. I only really ever do shows if I have to promote something. But this was always on my bucket list. It's like, I got to do that. Oh, and you are on our list. It should be known. There was a lot of schedule stuff over the last year and a half. We tried to get you a few times because we wanted you. I wanted you big time bad. So you can ask your piece. I fought it, but man, was I wrong? I mean, look, this was great. Ask our mutual peep.
杰克，我们占用你太多时间了，伙计。是的，确实是。我喜欢这样。能请到你真是太棒了。真是个可爱的人。你是最棒的。嘿，你知道吗，当我第一次听到你们节目时，我就想，噢，该死，我应该试着上那个节目。但我后来意识到我不喜欢做节目，因为我上节目太紧张了。我真的只有在必须宣传什么的时候才会做节目。但这一直在我的愿望清单上。就像，我一定要做那个。噢，你在我们的名单上。这应该广为人知。过去一年半里有很多日程安排的问题。我们试过几次联系你，因为我们需要你。我非常非常想要你。所以你可以问问你的经纪人。我争取过，但伙计，我错了吗？我是说，看，这太棒了。问问我们共同的朋友。
And then there was a lot of sketch. And I had a look you up right when you came on. Jack, we love you. Yeah, Jack, you're the best, man. The feeling is huge. Yeah. Quick plug on the way out the door. No, just kidding. Yeah, quick, quick plug. If you have anybody else you'd like to throw a plug. Yeah. Jack, yes. Love you. Thank you, Jack. Love you. Thanks, buddy. Bye, pal. Say hi to Kyle, please. I will say hi to Kyle. He's going to be jealous that I partied with you guys without you. Let's do a one for all times sake poker game ceremony. Let's do it. Let's do that. All right, cool. All right, Pally. Ciao, ciao. Bye, Jack. He was on my list, Jack. He was on my list. And then we did, for real, have some
然后有很多日程安排的问题。你刚来的时候我还得查查你的资料。杰克，我们爱你。是的，杰克，你是最棒的，伙计。这种感觉是相互的。是的。出门前快速宣传一下。不，开个玩笑。是的，快速，快速宣传一下。如果你还有其他人想推荐宣传一下。是的。杰克，是的。爱你。谢谢你，杰克。爱你。谢谢，伙计。再见，朋友。请代我向凯尔问好。我会向凯尔问好的。他会嫉妒我没带他一起和你们聚会。让我们为了往日情谊再举行一次扑克游戏仪式吧。我们来做吧。就这么办。好的，酷。好的，伙计。再见，再见。再见，杰克。他在我的名单上，杰克。他在我的名单上。然后我们确实，真的有一些
sketch issues in the great Louis K, who we all love and adore. Great shout out. But also had a tough time pulling that together because of sketch. And I don't want to throw Louis under the bus again. Oh, you have the same publicist? Yeah. Oh. But he's also, you know, a friend. Right. But if he was a better publicist, probably would have put him on the show earlier. But probably. Listen, Louis K is, you know, he does the best he can. He's still working on getting a full last name, but so he's busy. How great is Jack though? That Jack Black. I'd like more Jack Black in my life. He's such a mega talent, isn't he? Yeah, he is. You know, he's one of those people too, like you can make you laugh with just one word. Like the way he's,
日程安排的问题，还有我们都爱戴的伟大的路易·CK。很棒的致敬。但也因为日程安排很难协调。我不想再把路易推向风口浪尖。噢，你们有同一个公关人员？是的。噢。但他也是，你知道，一个朋友。对。但如果他是个更好的公关，可能早就让他上节目了。但可能吧。听着，路易·CK，你知道，他尽力了。他还在努力争取一个完整的姓氏，所以他很忙。杰克不是很棒吗？那个杰克·布莱克。我希望我的生活中能有更多的杰克·布莱克。他真是个超级天才，不是吗？是的，他是。你知道，他也是那种人，比如他只用一个词就能让你发笑。就像他那种，
he uses his face or whatever. Or just like a look. I just start grinning as soon as I see him because he's so comfy in his skin and he's just a smooth dude. He's like Ferrell. He falls into that category with me with Ferrell. Well, like, you know, anytime Will walks in the room and you're like, Oh my God. And I feel the same way about Jack. Yeah. He's fantastic. He's been in so many hit movies. Well, and there were a lot more movies that he would be in back. What was it? 10 years ago when comedies, they used to make a lot more comedies. I just don't get why they don't do that. They don't make sitcoms anymore and they don't make comedies studios anymore. They don't make movies anymore. They don't really make movies. Well, let me tell you something. You know what's
他运用他的面部表情什么的。或者只是一个眼神。我一看到他就开始咧嘴笑，因为他对自己非常自在，他就是一个圆滑的家伙。他就像法瑞尔。他和法瑞尔在我心中属于同一类。嗯，就像，你知道，任何时候威尔走进房间，你都会觉得，噢天哪。我对杰克也有同样的感觉。是的。他太棒了。他演过那么多热门电影。嗯，而且他本来会演更多的电影。那是什么时候？10年前，当喜剧片，他们过去拍更多的喜剧片。我只是不明白为什么他们不那样做了。他们不再制作情景喜剧，也不再制作喜剧电影公司了。他们不再拍电影了。他们真的不再拍电影了。嗯，让我告诉你一件事。你知道什么
doing really well is sci-fi and Jack says he wants to do sci-fi. Yeah, I would love to see Jack do a sci-fi. Jack starring in like a big sci-fi. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. What would you call, what would you call a sci-fi comedy? Let's try to work by into this title of this. Okay. Oh, wow. You're just saying it out loud. Yeah. You're just saying, you know, just identifying it. I think the audience is smart enough. They know we're not, we're not going to sneak up. He's got Kung Fu Panda on Netflix. I just wanted to say for his benefit because he never would say it. But you know what, Jason, back to your point. You know what, Rhymes are a sci-fi. Well, yeah, no, he knows. No, he just said it out loud. Are you just, are you just going to say
做得很好吗？是科幻片，杰克说他想拍科幻片。是的，我很乐意看到杰克拍科幻片。杰克主演一部大型科幻片。是的，当然。是的。你会怎么称呼，你会怎么称呼一部科幻喜剧？让我们试着把“双”（bi）这个词放进这个标题里。好的。噢，哇。你只是把它大声说出来了。是的。你只是，你知道，只是指出了它。我觉得观众足够聪明。他们知道我们不会，我们不会偷偷摸摸的。他在Netflix上有《功夫熊猫》。我只是想为了他的利益说出来，因为他永远不会自己说。但你知道吗，杰森，回到你的观点。你知道吗，押韵是科幻片。嗯，是的，不，他知道。不，他只是大声说出来了。你只是，你只是要说
bi-fi? No, it's going to say sci-fi. No, no, no, no, no. We have to come up with the title. What is the title of a science fiction comedy? Okay. No, no, hang on. I need, before we get to that, I just need to get to, Sean, you were just going to replace it with bi? Yeah. Yeah. No, he was just going to say sci-fi? Bi-aliens, bi-aliens. Bi-aliens. No, it doesn't work. Bi-aliens. Do better. Bi-aliens. No, how about Star Buyers? No? What? Holy fuck. Star Trek, bye. Oh my god. What the fuck is happening? No, I'm mocking Sean here. Oh, okay. Yeah. Are you? I like sci-bi. Sci-bi? Sci-bi doesn't even make sense. What about you, Will? Yeah,
双幻（bi-fi）？不，我是要说科幻（sci-fi）。不，不，不，不，不。我们必须想出一个标题。科幻喜剧的标题是什么？好的。不，不，等等。我需要，在我们讨论那个之前，我只需要，肖恩，你刚才打算用“双”来代替它？是的。是的。不，他刚才只是要说科幻（sci-fi）？双外星人，双外星人。双外星人。不，这行不通。双外星人。做得更好点。双外星人。不，星际双（Star Buyers）怎么样？不？什么？该死。星际迷航，再见。噢天哪。到底发生了什么？不，我是在嘲笑肖恩。噢，好的。是的。你是吗？我喜欢科幻双（sci-bi）。科幻双？科幻双甚至说不通。你呢，威尔？是的，
because it's at the end. Let's have, what's a classic, about 2001 space biology? No? No. How about Bicentennial Man? Oh, yes. Right on with Robin Williams. Okay, there it is. Bicentennial. You guys are the worst. Smart, lost. Smart, lost. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Arbjörf. Smart, lost. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为它在最后。让我们来个，什么是经典的，关于2001太空生物学？不？不。那《机器管家》（Bicentennial Man）怎么样？噢，是的。罗宾·威廉姆斯演的那个。好的，就是它。两百周年。你们是最差劲的。Smart, lost。Smart, lost。SmartList是由Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Arbjörf手工制作的100%有机艺术品。Smart, lost。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。